WELCOME TO THE GAME AWARDS.
WELCOME TOTO THE GAME AWARDS.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE SHOW IS ABOUT TO BEGIN.
♪ ♪
♪♪
>> HERE WE GO, WELCOME TO THE
AWARDS SHOW, I'M GEOFF KEIGHLEY
THE MAIN SHOW IS ON ITS WAY AT
THE TOP OF THE HOUR BUT RIGHT
HERE WERE GOING TO RECAP WHAT'S
ON THE WAY, PRESENT SOME GAME
AWARDS AND UNVEIL SOME OF THE
MANY UNFORESEEN WORLD PREMIERES,
THIS IS THE FIFTH YEAR OF THE
GAMEME AWARDS I C CAN'T BELIEVE.
EACH YEAR WE TRY TO BUILD ON THE
MOMENTS YOU LOVE WITH WHAT WE
HEAR LOUD AND CLEAR FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S A LITTLE INTIMATE EVENT
BECAUSE WE GOT A GREAT
RESPONSES, WERE MAKING IT A
BIGGER AND BETTER PART OF THE
SHOW, WE ARE EXPANDING THE REACH
TOO MANY MORE PLATFORMS SO
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WATCH IT
AROUND THE WORLD WHICH IS
IMPORTANT, WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE
SHARE OUR NIGHT.
WE ARE ALLOWING PEOPLE TO VOTE
IN NEW WAYS, GAMERS GET TOCHOOSR
JUDGE BOARD AND AT THIS YEAR YOU
CAN VOTE ON DISCORD, SERVER,
TWITTER, FACEBOOK, EVEN WITH
YOUR VOICE ON AMAZON ALEXA AND
GOOGLE SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE MORE NEW GAMES ANNOUNCND
BEING THIS YEAR AT THE SHOW THAN
EVER BEFORE WHICH IS REALLY
EXCITING, A LOT OF STUDIOS
AROUND THE WORLD ARE WORKING IN
SECRET TO PREPARE FOR THE GAME
AWARDS.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND LAST
YEAR THAT FANS REALLY LIKED WERE
GIVEAWAYS AND SPECIAL INCENTIVES
TO WATCH THE SHOW ANDD EARN
THINGS.
STEAM WE DID A GAME GIVEAWAY
WHICH IS AMAZING, PEOPLE GOT
EXCITEDND WERE WATCHING THE
SHOW AND STEVE WOULD DROP GAMES
INTO YOUOUR ACCOUNT I IF YOU'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH.
WE ARE DOING THAT AGAIAIN AND
EXPANDING IT IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
WE ALSO DO THE GAME AWARDS SALE,
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR GAMERS TO
GET SPECIAL OFFERS ON NOMINATED
GAMES.
THIS YEAR, WE ARE WORKING AGAIN
WITH PLAYSTATI STORE, XBOX,
NINTENDO E SHOP AND ESTEEM TO
CREATE A SPECIAL OFFERS ON
NOMINEES.
ME GAMES WILL BE ACROSS ALL,
SOME ONLY ON CERTAIN PLATFORMS,
I HOPE PEOPLE WILL SEE A GAME IN
THE SHOW AND SAY THAT'S AMAZING,
I WANT TO BUY THIS GAME IF I GET
A SPECIAL OFFER LET ME GO GRAB
IT.
THE STORIES THAT MATTER TO ME
COMING OUT OF THE SHOW W WITH
THESE GAME DEVELOPERS THEY WILL
CALL ME UP ON THE MONDAY AFTER
HER AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT WAS COOL WE WERE IN THE SHOW
BUT WE SOLD A LOT OF GAMES THIHS
WEEKEND.
THAT MAKES ALL THE HARD WORK
WORTHWHILEOR EVERYON ON THE
TEAM TO KNOW THESE DEVELOPERS
HAVE A PLATFORM AND WE CAN DRIVE
AN AUDIENCE TO CHECK OUT A GAME.
2018 WAS AN INCREDIBLE YEAR IN
GAMING AND WSAY IT EVERY YEAR
BUT THIS INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO
GET BIGGER AND BETTER.
WE'VE BEEN USING THIS TAG LINE
"WILL CHANGE" AND PEOEOPLE THINK
IT'S AN ANNOUNCEMENT OF A GAME
BUT IT MEANS A LOT OF EXISTING
GAMES HAVE EVOLVED THIS YEAR AND
IN UNIQUE AND DIFFERENT WAYS.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE IN GAME
STORYTELLING "FORTNITE" HASAS DE
WITH THE ROCKET LAUNCH IN THE
CUBE AND OTHER GAMES HAVE
OLVED LIKE "NO MAN'S SKY,"
IT'S A COMPLETELY NEW MAN'S GAM
GAME.
"WORLDS WILL CHANGE" INDICATES
GAMES WILL PLAY AND EVOLVE OVER
TIME.
IT USED TO BE THAT YOU PLAY THEE
GAME AND MOVE ON, NOW YOU KEEP
THOSE GAMES IN YOUR SYSTEMS AND
WHAT Y'RE GOINGNG TO SEE THIS
YEAR IS A LOT OF THESE ONGOING
GAMES ARE GOING TO EVOLVE IN OUR
SHOW TOO.
THAT'S A TEASE OF THAT THEME
THAT THE WORLDS YOU KNOW, YOU
MAY NOT KNOW ANY MORE AFTER THE
GAME AWARDS.
WE OFTEN GET ASKED HOW WE PICK
THE WINNERS FOR "THE GAME
AWARDS."
THE NOMINEES ARE SELECTED BY A
JURY OF PRESS FROM AROUND THE
WORL THERE ARE 65 DIFFERENT
PUBLICATIONS AND THEY OFTEN HAVE
STAFFS THAT HAVE PLAYED ALL OF
THESE GAMES.
IF WE THINK THAT'S THE BEST WAY
TO SURVEY EVERYTHING OUT THERE
IN A NEUTRAL AGNOSTIC WAY AND
SAY HERE ARE THE GAMES WE THINK
ARE THE BEST OF THE BEST..
THOSE LEAD TO THE NOMINEES WHICH
HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED AND THE
WINNERS S HAVE BEEN SELECTED BYA
BLENDED VOTE BETWEEN THE JURY
ANDD THE PUBLIC THAT GETS TO VOE
AND HELP INFLUENENCE IT.
SOME PEOPLE SAY WHY DON'T YOU DO
100% FAN VOTING?
A LOT CAN BE SOCIALLY ENGINEERED
AND I DON'T WANT AWARDS TO GO TO
GAMES THAT JUST HAPPEN TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE MORE TWITTER
FOLLOWERS OR BUY A BUNCH OF ADS
TO CONVINCE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR THEM.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
RIGHT GAMES WIN AND WE HAVE AN
AUTHENTIC, CREDIBLE PROCESS AND
THAT'S HOW WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE VOTING IN "THE GAME
AWARDS"
."
GAME OF THE YEAR IS A
COMPETITIVE CATEGORY IN 2018.
"SPIDER-MAN" OR RED DEAD
REDEMPTION, OR WILL IT BE "GOD
OF WAR," "CELESTE," ASSASSIN'S
CREED ODYSSEY, OR "MONSTER
HUNTER: WORLD"
."
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT AT THE
END OF THE NIGHT.
BUT RIGHT NOW HERE'S A LOOK AT
OUR FIRST WORLD PREMIERE.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAK OUT EVERYONE WATCHING
AROUND THE WORLD, I'M GEOFF
KEIGHLEY AND WELCOME TO "THE
GAME AWARDS" 2018, IS EVERYBODY
READY FOR A BIG SHOW?
THIS IS SO EXCITING WE HAVE OUR
BIGGEST SHOW EVER COMING UP AT
THE TOP OF THE HOUR, SO MUCH
NEWS, SO MANY SURPRISES, WE ARE
STREAMING LIVE AROUND THE WORLD
AND OVER 45 PLATFORMS, I WANT TO
SAY HI TO EVERYONE WATCHING IN
CHINA, INDIA, ALL ACROSS THE
WORLD I KNOW IT'S LATE IN EUROPE
BUT STICK AROUND WE HAVE AN
AMAZING SHOW AHEAD FOR YOU WITH
SOME AWARDS AND GAME
ANNOUNCEMENTS II KNOW EVERYO IS
ANTICIPATING THINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO KICK OFF THE
SHOW BEFORE WE GET TO THE MAIN
SHOW AT THE TOP OF THE HOUR WITH
A GUY WHO MADE SOME HEADLDLINES
LAST YEAR, JOSEPH FERENCE BACK
AT THE GAME AWARDS.
>> IT'S NICE TO BE THE FIRST
GUEST.
YOU SHOULULD HAVE THE AWARD, LOK
ATHAT YOU'VE PUT TOGETHER.
IT'S CRAZY, FIVE YEARS, I
IMAGINE IN TEN YEARS WHAT YOU
WILL DO.
I'M HAPPY TO BE BACK HERE
>> Geoff: YOU'RE A NOMINEE AS
WELL FOR BEST GAME DIRECTION FOR
A WAY OUT.
>> I'M EXPECTING TO WIN.
>> Geoff: I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
YOUR SPEECH.
WE ARE EXCITED TO HAVE YOYOU HEE
TONIGHT.
THINTERNET WTS TO HEAFROM
YOU, HOW DO YOU THINK WE ARE
DOING THISIS YEAR?
>> WE JUST STARTED BUT I FEEL
LIKE IT'S BECOMING BIGGERND
BIGGER, I'M TELLING YOU -- FIVE
YEARS THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
CRAZIEST THING IN THE WHOLE
WORLD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A LAPTOP
CONNECTION, LAST YEAR WHEN I WAS
HERE PEOPLE THOUGHT I WAS CRAZY,
I AM A BIT CRAZY BUT IT'S THE
AUDIENCE, THE WAY THEY WERE -- I
CAN'T SEE THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, IT'S GREAT
TO BE HERE.
>> Geoff: YOU ARE HERE FOR
ANOTHER PURPOSE RIGHT NOW, WE
ARE GOING TO GIVE AWAY OUR FIRST
AWARD OF THE EVENING FOR BEST
ACTION GAME AND LET'S TAKE A
LOOK RIGHT NOW ATHE NOMINEE
THIS YEAR AS VOTED ON BY T
JURY AND FANS, "CALL OF DUTY"
BLACK OPS FOUR, "DEAD CELLS"
,"
DESTY TWO FORSAKEN, FAR CRY 5,
AND "MEGA MAN 11".
>> THE BEST ACTION GAME IS "DEAD
CELLS"!
>> Geoff: THE STAGE IS YOURS.
CONGRATULATIONS, HOW DOES IT
FEEL?
>> IT'S SO UNEXPECTED, JUST A
SPECIAL THOUGHT F THE WHOLE
TEAM BACK IN FRANCECE HOPEFULLY
WATCHING US AT 3:00 A.M. IN THE
MORNING.
YOU JUST MADE IT, SO
CONGRATULATIONS YOU SHOULD BE
PROUD OF YOURSELF.
>> Geoff: AN INCREDIBLE GAME,
LONG TIME COMING.
>> SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR FANS,
WE COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
>> Geoff: THE GAME IS
INCREDIBLE, YOU GUYS DID A GREAT
JOB.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ALL THEHE Y
TO "THE GAME AWARDS," YOUR FIRST
OF MANY WE HOPE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER TROPHY WITH
YOUR NAME ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'VE GOT SOME MORE WORLD
PREMIERES TO GET TO YOU BEFORE
WE GET TO THE MAIN SHOW AT THE
TOP OF THE HOUR, RIGHT NOW WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FIRST GAME FROM A NEW STUDIO UP
IN MONTREAL, TYPHOON, PUBLISHED
BY 505.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS TITLE.
♪ ♪
>> BREACH.
CABIN PRESSURE INCREASING.
>> ONCE AGAIN, WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING THE
PROGRAM.
FOR THE EIGHGHTH YEAR RUNNING,
WE'VE BEEN VOTED THE FOURTH BEST
INTERSTELLAR EXPLORATION COMPANY
BY OUR PEERS.
>> OXYGEN LEVELS CRITICAL.
>> GOVERNMENT FUNDING HAS
ALLOWED US TO LAUNCH EVEN MORE
HAPPY EXPLORERS AROUND SPACE.
>> MADE
MAY DAY, THIS IS NOT.
>> ONE DAY IT WILL BE YOUR
PLANETS THAT WILL PROVIDE A
FUTURE HOME FOR HUMANITY.
ONWARD TO ADVENTURE!
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]E]
>> Geoff: FIRST OF ALL,
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS ABOUT
15 YEARS, MAKING GAMES FOR OTHER
PEOPLE.
IT'S INCREDIBLY AMAZING TO SEE A
GAME W WE BUILT ON OUR OWN FROM
NOTHING, TO SEE IT AT YOUR SHOW
ON THE BIG SCREEN IS SUPER
FULFILLING.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY.
>> Geoff: TELL US A BIT ABOUT
IT, WHAT KIND OF GAME IS AT?
>> WATCH THE TEASER, IS IT A
BATTLE ROYALE?
IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT'S NOT A SURVIVAL GAME, IT'S
AN ADVENTURE GAVE YOU GET
DROPPED ON A STRANGE ALIEN WORLD
FOR A COMPANY CALLED KINDRED
AEROSPACE WHO ARE VERY PROUD TO
BE THE FOURTH BEST INTERSTELLAR
SPACE EXPLORATION COMPANY.
THEY DROP YOU THERE WITH NO
GEAR, HIGH HOPES, NO ABILITY,
AND HOPE YOU CAN SOLVE THE
MYSTERY ON WHAT'S ON THE SAVAGE
PLANET.
>> Geoff: HOW CAN WE FIND MORE
ABOUT THIS GAME?
>> NOT MUCH GAMEPLAY UNTIL NEXT
YEAR BUT WE WILL SHOW YOU GAME
PLAY AND ALL KINDS OF NEW BITS
AND PIECES AS SOON AS WE START
NEXT YEAR.
>> Geoff: ALEX, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING DOWN AND SHOWING
YOUR GAME FOR THE FIRST TIME
HERE AT "THE GAME AWARDS"
."
NOW WE'RE GOING TO PRESENT
ANOTHER AWARD NOW FOR BEST
ROLE-PLAYING GAME AND THE
NOMINEES OF THIS GENRE CATEGORY
ARE DRAGON QUEST XI.
"MONSTER HUNTER: WORLD"
."
NI NO KUNI 2.
OCTOPATH TRAVELER, AND PILLARS
OF PATERNITY II READ THE WINNERE
BEST ROLE-PLAYING GAME GOES
TO "MONSTER HUNTER: WORLD"
."
CONGRATULATIONS.
THIS IS FOR YOU GUYS.
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
PHOTO OFF!
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> IT'S GREAT THAT WE ACTUALLY
WERE ABLE TO COME FROM JAPAN.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> WHEN WE BEGAN CREATING THIS
GAME WE WERE TALKING AMONGST THE
TEAM MEMBERS, IT WAS OUR GOAL TO
BE HERE AND RECEIVE THE AWARD.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> SO WE MADE IT.
IF >> Geoff: CLOSED CIRCLE.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> WE WILL HAVE GREAT NEWS FOR
OUR FANS SOON.
>> Geoff: HOW SOON, LIKE
TONIGHT?
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
>> A FEW DAYS LATER.
SCRATCH THAT OFF YOUR BINGO
CARD, CONGRATULATIONS ON WINNING
THE BEST RPG AND NOMINATED FOR
GAME OF THE YEAR AS WELL.
>> Geoff: THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF GAMING CONVERSATION HAPPENING
ON TWITTER, TWITTER DECIDED TO
CREATE THE FIRST TWITTER GAMING
AWARD AND THE WINNER OF ALL THE
THING THAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR
WAS SPIDER-MAN'S PS4 PHOTO MODE.
SEE THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THAT
WINTER AND TWEET UP A STORM ALL
NIGHT ABOUT "THE GAME AWARDS,"
THERE IS SOME BIG NEWS BREAKING
THAT YOU'LL WANT TO BE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE ARE ALSO BACK ON TWITCH WE
HAVE AN INTERACTIVE EXTENSION
THAT LETS YOU PREDICT THE
WINNERS THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
YOU CAN GO ONLINE TO THE GAME
AWARDS CHANNEL AND WILL SHARE
THE FINAL LEADERBOARD TO SEE WHO
PICKED T MOST AWARARDS CORRECTL
CORRECTLY.
SOME OTHER AWARDS TO GET TO
KNOW, IT'S BEEN A HUGE YEAR FOR
EASTPORT'S COMING UP AT THE TOP
OF THE HOUR, THE BEST eSPORTS
PLAYER AWARD PRESENTED BY OHMAN
BY HP BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S MY
HONOR TO ANNOUNCE SOME OF THE
OTHER WINNERS -- THE BEST
ESPORTS TEAM, HERE ARE THE
NOMINEES.
CLOUD NINE HAS WON THIS THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
IF THE WINNER THIS YEAR AGAIN IS
CLOUD NINE, CONGRATULATIONS TO
JACK AND THE ENTIRE ORGANIZATIO
ORGANIZATION.
FOR THE BEST eSPORTS GAME, THE
NOMINEES THIS YEAR WERE
COUNTERSTRIKE GO, "FORTNITE,"
LEAGUE OF LEGENDS, "OVERWATCH,"
DOTA 2, AND THE GAME AWARD GOES
TO "OVERWATCH" FOR THE BEST
ESPORTS GAME.
I THINK THAT WON LESTER AS WELL.
THE BEST eSPORTS EVENTS,
NOMINEES OR A NEW CATEGORY THIS
YEAR.
THE BEST HE SPORTS EVENT, THE
LEAGUE OF LEGENDS WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP EVENT, THE
"OVERWATCH" LEAGUE GRAND FINALS,
AND THE INTERNATIONAL 2018 UP IN
VANCOUVER.
THE LEGAL LEGENDS WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP WINS,
CONGRATULATIONS TO LOL.
THE BEST eSPORTS HOST.
ALEX MENDEZ, ALEX RICHARDSOSON,-
AND THE GAME AWARD GOES TO
SJOKZ.
BEST eSPORTS COACH.
THE BEST eSPORTS COACH AS
VOTED BY THE FANS, REAPERRED.
BEST eSPORTS MOMENT, WAS C9'S
COMEBACK, OG'S MASSIVE UPSET OF
LGT AND SONICIC FOX WAS A NOMINE
FOR BEST eSPORTS PLAYER SITES
WHICH.
THE WINNER IS OBRA DINN'S
COMEBACK WIN IN TRIPLE OT VERSUS
FAZA.
WE'VE GOT MORE eSPORTS COMING
UP IN THE MAIN SHOW BUT RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER WORLD
PREMIERE, A FAVORITE GAME OF
MINE FROM A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
AND THEY REACHED OUT TO ME AND
SAID WE'VE GOT SOMETHING MORE WE
ARE DOING.
CHECK THIS OUT.
♪ ♪
>> THIS IS A STORY OF A
VIDEO GAME CALLED THE STANLEY
PARABLE.
IT WAS THE VIDEO GAME SENSATION
OF 2013.
ALL THOSE AWARDS WE WERE
NOMINATED FOR?
>> THIS YEAR'S WINNER FOR BEST
NARRATIVE IT IS THE LAST OF US.
THE LAST OF US.
>> IT WAS THRILLING TO BE SO
UNANIMOUSLY RECOGNIZED BY OUR
PEERS.
WE'VE LOCKED THE GAME'S SOURCE
CODE AWAY WHERE IT CAN NEVER BE
TOUCHED BY THE GREEDY HAND OF
CAPITALISM, A PRISTINE TIME
CAPSULE OF PERFECT ARTISTIC
INTEGRITY TO BE PRESERVED FOR --
WAIT, WHAT DO YOU MEAN WE NEVER
PUT THE GAME ON CONSOLES?
OF COURSE WE PUT IT ON CONSOLES.
WE DIDN'T, EXCUSE ME A MOMENT.
>> STANLEY!
STANLEY!
STANLEY.
STANLEY, I'VE HAD A GREAT IDEA,
I WANT TO ADD NEW ENDINGS AND
NEW CONTENT, NEW ADVENTURES FOR
YOU.
WON'T IT BE FUN?
OF COURSE IT WILL.
WE'LL PACKAGE IT UP WITH THE
ORIGINAL GAME AND PUT IT ON
CONSOLES AND EVERYONE WILL BUY
IT AGAIN BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUCKERS.
COME, COME, DADDY NEEDS A THIRD
SWIMMING POOL.
[APPLAUSE]
WHAT DO YOU MEAN THE LAST OF
US 2 IS ALSO COMING OUT NEXT
YEAR?
>> Geoff: ALL RIGHT, THE
STANLEY PARABLE BACK AGAIN.
NOW IT'S MY HONOR TO PRESENT THE
AWARD FOR BEST STUDENT GAME,
JUDGED BY MEGAN ELLISON ALLISON,
TODD HOWARD, AND MY GOOD FRIEND
HIDEO KOJIMA.
THE NOMINEES ARE COMBAT 2018, --
QUASAR, LIFE FROM FRANCE AND
RECHARGE FROM MIT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THE BEST
STUDENT GAME AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO ALL THE STUDENTS HERE WITH US
IN THE AUDIENCE.
THE BEST STUDENT GAME GOES TO
"COMBAT 2018."
>> IT FEELS AMAZING TO BE UP
HERE FOR THE STUDENT GAME,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS AWARD.
>> Geoff: HOPEFULLY YOUR GAME
WILL COME OUT SOON, YOU'LL GET
TO PLAY AT.
>> IT HAS A NEW NAME.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR US AND
OF COURSE OUR TEAM ON STAGE WITH
ME.
OF COURSE OUR SCHOOL IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF APPLIED SCIENCES
AND OF COURSE OUR MENTOR.
>> Geoff: CONGRATULATIONS, WE
HOPE TO SEE MORE OF YOUR GAME.
BEST STUDENT GAME AWARD WINNER.
ANOTHER WORLD PREMIERE, THIS IS
FROM AN INDIE TEAM OF THREE GUYS
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
GAME FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
WHEN I SAW SOME FOOTAGE OF THIS
I SAID I GOT TO SHARE IT WITH
YOU.
CHECK THIS OUT.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: TOP OF THE HOUR,
THAT MEANS I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
"THE GAME AWARDS," ARE YOU GUYS
READY?
THIS SHOW IS ALL ABOUT BRINGING
EVERYONE TOGETHER TO CELEBRATE
VIDEO GAMES.
WHEN I STARTED THIS SHOW, MY
DREAM WAS TO PUT COMPETITION
ASIDE AND COME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE EVERYTHING WE LOVOVE.
PLAYING GAMES, MAKING GAMES,
THIS IS A MOMENT THAT'S BEEN
FIVE YEARS IN THE MAKING FOR ME.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT TO
HAPPEN BUT TO KICK OFF THE SHOW
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING BETTER
THAN THIS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING FROM
NINTENDO, REGGIE FILS-AIME.
FROM PLAYSTATION SHAWN LAYDEN.
AND FROM XBOX, PHIL SPENCER.
♪ ♪
>> TONIGHT AT THE GAME AWARDS,
WE COME TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY
TO CELEBRATE VIDEO GAMES, THE
MOST COMPELLING AND IMMERSIVE
FORM OF ENTERTAINMENT IN THE
WORLD.
>> AS AN INDUSTRY, WE ARE MOST
POWERFUL WHEN WE COME TOGETHER,
UNITED BY OUR COMMON LOVE FOR
THE ART FORM OF GAMES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE JOIN WITH THE VIEWERS AND
GAMERS AROUND THE GLOBE TO
CELEBRATE CREATIVITY, INNOVATIO
INNOVATION, AND THE ROLE THAT
VIDEO GAMES PLAY IN POPULAR
CULTURE.
>> TOGETHER WE WILL CONTINUE TO
INVITE NEW VOICES, CREATORS, AND
PLAYERS INTO OUR WORLDS, BECAUSE
WHEN EVERYBODY PLAYS, WE ALL WI
WIN.
>> BECAUSE WHEN WE SEE THE
STRENGTH OF A UNITED GAMING
COMMUNITY, WE REMEMBER THAT
WE'VE NEVER SEEN A CHALLENGE
THAT YOU CAN'T DEFEAT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE ARE UNITED IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO LEADING AND
PUSHING THIS INDUSTRY FORWARD
WITH NEW GAMES, NEW EXPERIENCES,
AND DO WAYS FOR EVERYONE TO PLA
PLAY.
GOOD LUCK TO ALL THE NOMINEES.
>> AND CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL
THE WINNERS.
>> AND ENJOY "THE GAME AWARDS"
"
TAKE IT AWAY.
>> Geoff: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
REGGIE, SEAN,
, AND IT FILLED
TOGETHER STAGE.
WE HAVE AN AMAZING SHOW
TOGETHER, WERE GOING TO KICK IT
OFF WITH AN INCREDIBLE
PERFORMANCE BY THE GAME AWARDS
ORCHESTRA CONDUCTED BY OUR
AMAZING MUSICICAL DIRECTOR
FEATURING THE LEGENDARY HANS
ZIMMER, THEY WILL BE JOINED BY E
PREMIERING OUR BRAND-NEW THEME
FOR "THE GAME AWARDS," I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT.
ENJOY THE SHOW.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> HERE IS THE CREATOR OF "THE
GAME AWARDS," GEOFF KEIGHLEY.
>> Geoff: AMAZING, HOW ABOUT
THAT?
"THE GAME AWARDS" ORCHESTRA,
WHAT AN AMAZING START TO THE
SHOW.
WELCOME TO "THE GAME AWARDS"
EVERYBODY!
WOW, WE ARE LIVE AROUND THE
WORLD ON OVER 45 PLATFORMS AND
TONIGHT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD ARE COMING
TOGETHER TO DO ONE THING WHICH
IS CELEBRATE THE VIDEO GAMES
THAT WE LOVE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING ME AND
THANK YOU, WE'VE GOT AN AMAZING
SHOW FOR YOU.
FILLED WITH AWARDS, SOME NEW
GAME ANNOUNCEMENTS, MANY THINGS
YOU'VE BEE ROOM BURNED ONLINE
MAY HAPPEN TONIGHT AND WE HAVE
AN AMAZING YEAR FOR GAMES.
LET'S GET RIGH TO THE SHOW WITH
OUR FIRST BIG AWARD OF THE
NIGHT.
HE'S A MEGA POPULAR YOUTUBE HER,
SHE'S A TWITCH STREAM OR
NOMIMINATED TONIGHT CONTENT
CREATOR OF THE YEAR.
PLEASE WELCOME JACK AND POKIMAN
POKIMANE.
>> WE ARE PRETTY LUCKY THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO PLAY GAMES FOR A
LIVING, TO ALL THE DEVELOPERS
HERE AND WATCHING AROUND THE
WORLD, THANK YOU FOR DOING WHAT
YOU DO END MAKING THE GAMES THAT
WE LOVE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Y, THANK YOU.
WE ARE HERE TO PRESE THE AWARD
FOR BEST NARRATIVE, THESE ARE
THE GAMES WHOSE STORIES
CAIVATED US WITH COMPLEX
CHARACTERS, SURPRISING TWISTS
D PROFOUND PHILOSOPHICAL
IDEAS.
>> HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
>> BEST NARRATIVE.
>> I DIDN'T CHOOSE TOE
DIFFERT.
>> TWO BETRAYS MY OWN KIND.
>> YOU DID.
>> THE ROAD AHEAD IS LONG, BOY.
YOU MUST BE A WARRIOR.>> THIS I.
>> I KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND WHAT
YOU DID.
>> WHAT YOU AND YOUR BRBROTHER
HAVE IS THE MOST IMPORTANT T TH
THING.
>> HE'S IN DANGER, HE NEEDS OUR
HELP.
>> ANYONE LEFT IN NEW YORK
DOESN'T WANT ME DEAD?
>> BE CAREFUL OUT THERE.
IT'S NASTY COUNTRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THE GAME AWARD GOES TO RED
DEAD REDEMPTION 2.
♪ ♪
>> THANK YOUROM THE ENTIRE
AM AT ROCK STAR TO ALL OF OUR
FANS, EVERYONE WHO VOTED FOR US,
WE LOVE TELLING STORIES JUST AS
MUCH AS WE LOVE CRAZY WORLDS AND
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE SEEIN
PEOPLE CONNECT TO THE GAME AND
GOING ON THIS JOURNEY FOR
THEMSELVES.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
AMAZING CAST, THEY BROUGHT US TO
LIFE IN WAYS WE DIDN'T EVEN
IMAGINE AND YOU CAN SEE TONIGHT
ACROSS THIS CATEGORY, IT'S BEEN
AN OUTSTANDING YEAR FOR GAMES
AND STORYTELLING.
THERE'S STILL SO FAR WE CAN TAKE
IT.
ONTO THE NEXT ONONE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE FUTURE OF GAMES WITH
WORLD PREMIERES.
SOME OF THEM YOU'VE PROBABLY
HEARD OF ANDND SOME OF THEM YOU
DEFINITELY HAVEN'T.
WE'VE GOT GOOD SURPRISES TONIGHT
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THAT NO
ONE IS GOING TO SEE COMIMING --
ENJOY.
♪ ♪
>> IDIOTS, YOU STUPIDITY MAY
HAVE DOOMED THE UNIVERSE.
>> WOULDN'T BE THE FIRIRST TIME,
SWEETHEART.
>> A WHO OPPOSE OUR MASTER
SHALL FALL.
♪ ♪
>> I LIKE TO SEE YOU TRY,
SCRAP HEAP.
♪ ♪
>> WE DO IT AS A TEAM.
>> I SHALL B BE WAITING HERE FOR
YOU.
>>
HERE'S A JONAH HILL.
>> SHOUT OUT TO WOOOODY JACKSON,
THE BEST COMPOSER IN THE WORLD.
I AM HONORED TOO BE HERE TONIGHT
TO INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO HAS
CHANGED GAMING FOREVER, SOMEONE
WHO IN HIS OWN WORDS WANTED TO
MAKE KILLER GAMES WITH HIS
FRIENDS AND ENDED UP MAKING SOME
OF THE WORLD'S MOST MEMORABLE
TITLES.
30 YEAEARS AGO HIS FRIENDS STARD
WITH NOTHING, THEY WORKED IN A
SMALL BASEMENT UNDER A NURSE'S
CALL CENTER, THEY CREATED ICONIC
GAMES FOLLOWING A SIMPLE RECIPE.
HARD WORK, STRONG IDEAS AND A
PASSIONATE TEAM, THAT RECIPE
GAGAVE US NBA 2K.
GIVE IT UP.
♪ ♪
GREG IS A HUMBLE GIANT BUT HIS
FORWARD THINKING PASSION AND
DEDICATION TO E EXCELLENCE HAS
MADE HIS NAME KNOWN THROUGHOUT
THE INDNDUSTRY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK BACK AT HIS
HIGHLIGHT REEL.
>> INDUSTRY ICON.
♪ ♪
[WHISTLE BLOWING]
>> THIS IS THE NFLFL ON THE SEGA
SPORTS NETWORK.
>> LET'S SEE IF THEY CAN T TAKE
CARE OF BUSINESS.
>> WELCOME TO THESPN HALFTI
SHOW.
>> TOUCHDOWN!
>> HE SCORES, IT'S IN THE N NET!
THAT'S HOW YOU BLOW OUT THE
SPEAKERS!
>> MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL ACTION.
>> IF YOU SMELL!
>> THE NBA RIGHT HERE ON 2K
SPORTS.
>> THIS GAME IS BIGGER THAN THE
COURT.
>> THIS TEAM IS FAR FROM
FINISHED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> VERY COOL.
I'M HONORED TO INTRODUCE THE
2018 INDUSTRY ICON, THE LEGEND,
THE MYTH, THEOAT, MR. GREG
THOMAS.
♪ ♪
>> T THANK YOU, IT'S SUCH AN HOR
TO BE INTRODUCED BY YOU.
TO SEE A COMPILATION OF THE
GAMES WE'VE CREATED OVER THE
LAST 30 YEARS IS ALSO VERY
HUMBLING.
FOR ANYONE WHO KNOWS ME, YOU
KNOW I'VE SHIED AWAY FROM THE
SPOTLIGHT.
I'M NOT VERY COMFORTABLE BEING
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN ABOUT MAKING
A NAME FOR MYSELF, IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN ABOUT MAKING GREAEAT GAMES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE HONOR.
FIRST I NEED TO THINK MY
BEAUTIFUL WIFE AND FAMILY FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DO EVERYTHING I
ALWAYS WANTED TO DO.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY CRIFICES,
THEY HAVE BEEN PATIENT, LOYAL
AND UNDERSTANDING THROUGH IT
ALL.
I LOVE YOU ALLERY MUCH,
THANK YOU.
NOT OF THIS WOULD BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT MY BUSINESS PARTNER AND
COFOUNDER SCOTT PATTERSON AND MY
BROTHE AND LEADER OF THE NBA 2K
TEAM, JEFF THOMAS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER SINCE THE
VERY BEGINNING, AND WE'VE ALWAYS
SHARED THE SAME VALUES AND
PASSIONS WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING
GAMES.
WE NEVER IMAGINED THAT OVER THE
YEARS,ISUAL CONCEPTS WOULD
GROW WHERE WE ARE TO DATE WITH
SIX WORLDWIDE STUDIOS AND MORE
THAN 350 EMPLOYEES.
THE PHILOSOPHY HASS NEVER
CHANGED, IT'S ALL FAMY TO ME.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK CARL SLID M
2K AND TAKE TWO FOR GIVING US
THE FREEDOM TO MAKE GAMES OUR
WAY.
I OWE EVERYTHING TO MY
MANAGEMENT TEAEAM.
THIS TEAM HAS BEEN TOGETHER FOR
A LONGIME.
THE CULTURE OF THE COMPANY HAS
ALWAYS BEEEEN ABOUT BELIEVING IN
OUR PEOPLE.
IT'S BECAUSE WE LOVE WORKING
TOGETHER AND WE ALL BELIEVE INT.
I NEED TO THANK ALL OF THEIR
FAMILIES AS WELL FOR SUPPORTING
US AND PUTTING UP WITH US, THAT
CAN'T BE EASY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WITHOUT THESEEOPLE, THERERE ISS
NO GREG THOMAS RECEIVING AN
AWARD, THERE IS NO VISISUAL
CONCEPTS, THEY ARE THE REAL
ICONS AND I SHARE THIS AWARD
WITH THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCHH..
>> Geoff: TONIGHT TO THE GAME
AWARDS AND FACEBOOK GAMING ARE
RECOGNIZING GLOBAL GAMING
SYSTEMS, PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENRICHING THE LIVES OF OTHERS
AROUND THE WORLD THROUGH
VIDEO GAMES.
WE ARE GOING TO TELL SOME
STORIES OF THREE PEOPLE THINK
YOU SHOULD MEET AND HEAR THEIR
STORIES, I'M SO PROUD TO HAVE
THESE IN "THE GAME AWARDS"
."
FIRST UP, STEPHEN SPOHN FROMEVI
ABLE GAMERS.
>> ALL I WANTED TO DO WAS FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PLAY A VIDEO GAME AND
ALON THE WAY I FIGURED OUT I
COULD HELP OTHER PEOPLE PLAY
VIDEGAMES TOO.
WHEN I WAS COMING OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL, I WENT TO MYGUIDANT
WHAT'S NEXT FOR ME?
HE SAT ACROSS THE TABLE FROM ME
AND HE TOLD ME THAT I SHOULD GO
HOME AND HAVE FUN WI MY
REMAINING YEARS BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO DIE SOON ANYWAY.
THEY TOLD ME TO GO HOME AND DIE.
AT THE TIME IT KEPT ME DOWN BUT
NOW IT'S A MEMORY THAT I LK
BACK ON AND I REALIZE YOU CAN BE
DISABLED,, YOU CAN BE PRODUCTIV,
YOU CAN BE A VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF SOCTY,
D YOU CAN CHANGE THE WORLD BY
DOING A FEW THINGS ALONG THE WAY
AT NO ONELSE IS WIING TO
DO.
I'M PROUD TO BE ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF ABLE GAMERS TO HELPPF
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
MY MISSION IS TO ENABLE PEOPLE
TO REACH OUT, TO CONNECT WITH
THE WORLD THAT WAS ALWAYS
INACCESSIBLE.
THEY ARE ABLE TO HAVE A GREATER
QUALITY OF LIFE BY HIRING PEOPLE
IN THEIR LIVES.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: AMAZING.
FOUR YEARS AGO, ROCKET POWERED
SOCCER HAS NEVER BEEN THE SAME
WITH MORE THAN 52 MILLION
PLAYERS WORLDWIDE, IT'S 82 TIME
WINNER AT THE GAME AWARDS AND
NOW ROCKET LEAK IS REVEALING
THEIR LATEST DLC, CHECK IT OUT.
♪ ♪
♪  ♪
>> FIVE, FOUR, THREE, TWO, ONE,
ZERO.
LIFT OFF, WE HAVE A LIFTOFF!
♪ ♪
>> NEXT, THE AWARD FOR BEST
PERFORMANCE, AND LATER, MORE
SURPRISE GAME ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
MUMUSICAL PERFORMANCES.
THIS IS "THE GAME AWARDS" 2018.
>> THE TIME HAS COME FOR PADS T.
♪ ♪
>> SUPER SMASH BROTHERS
ULTIMATE, COMING SOON.
IN FT WE ARE HOURS AWAY!
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT
AN EXCLUSIVE ACTION-CKED
IPPED FROM A NEW FILM DIRECTED
BY ROBERT RODRIGUGUEZ AND PRODUD
BY JAM CAMERON, COMING TO
THEATERS FEBRUARY 14TH -- CHECK
THIS OUT.
♪ ♪
>> MY GOD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> FROM THE UPCOMING FILM,
EASE WELCOME TWO TIME
ACADEMY AWARD WINNENER CHRISTOPH
WALTZ.
>> TO DELIVER A POWERFUL
PERFORMANCE YOU MUST HUMANIZE A
DIGITAL PUPPET MADE OF POLYGONS
AN TEXTURES.
>> THEY ARE A SURROGATE FOR
THEIR AUDIENCNCE, AN ENTRY POINT
INTO THE GAMES WORLD AND
PERSONALITIES.
>> THE, UNLIKE ANY MEDIUM THE
CONNECON STRENGTHENS WHENN THE
PLAYER CONTROLOLS THEIR VERY
CHARACTER WITH AN ANALOG STICK.
>> I PREFER MOUSE AND KEYBOARD.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DO THIS WITH
YOU.
>> AIM ASSIST IS JUST HORRIBLE.
>> THESE ARE NOMINEES FOR BEST
PERFORMANCE.
>> BEST PERFORMANCE.
>> STRONG FEMALE CHARACTERS THAT
I HAPPEN TO KNOW.
>> I'LL HIDE WITH YOUOU
>> I DIDN'T CHOOSE TO BETRAY MY
OWN KIND.
FOLLOW ORDERERS.
>> IT TO EFFECTIVE, A WARRIOR
MUST NOT FEEL FOR HIS ENEMY.
WE ARE MORE THAN THAT.
>> SPIDER-MAN, NEXT TIME LEAVE
THE FIGHTING TO THE PROS.
>> NO MORE GHOSTS.
AS LONG AS WE GET PAID OR YOU
GET SHOT, I'M HAPPY.
>> THE GAME AWARD GOE TO ROGER
CLARK, AS ARTHUR MORGAN IN "RED
DEAD REDEMPTION 2".
♪ ♪
>> I GUESS THIS ISIS THE PART
WHERE WORDS THAT MAKE SENSE ARE
SUPPOSED TO COME OUT OF MY MOUT
MOUTH.
THANK YOU, I HUMBLY ACCEPT THIS
HONOR ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
AMAZING PERFORMANCES OF MY
FELLOW NOMINEES.
TOTO SHARE THIS MOMENT IN TIME
WITH ALL OF YOU, A MOMENT IN
TIME WHICH HAS CLEARLY BECOME
THE ADVENT OF A GOLDEN AGE OF
THIS MEDIUM, I'VE GOT TO THANK
MY WIFE MOLLY, I LOVOVE YOU -- R
FIVE YEARS, SHE WATCHED ME COME
HOME FROM LONG DAYS OF
PERFORMANCE CAPTURE AND WOULD
KINDLY REMIND ME TO CHECKRTHUR
AT THE DOOR,R, P PUT THE KIDS TO
BED -- REMINDS ME, COLLIN, LORI,
GO TO BED.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE T THANKROCK SG
OPPORTUNITY.
THE FAITH THAT THEY PUT IN ME.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU ALL -- THIS
IS AN AMAZING MOMENT!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> HE WAS THE NARRATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ONE OF THE BIGGEST NAMES IN
UBISOFT HISTORY, FAR CRY 5 AND
HE'S HERE TO REVEALL THE NEXTCH.
PLEASE WELCO JOHN SEBASTIAN TO
DECANTE.
♪ ♪
>> HELLO EVERYONE.
AS YOU MAY REMEMBER, FAR CRY
CRY 5 WAS NUKES DROPPING ON
MONTANA, AND THIS MONTH IS THE
VERY BEGINNING OA BRAND-NEW
WORLD.
AS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR OF THIS
NEW PROJECT, IT IMY ABSOLUTE
PRESSURE TO REVEAL TO Y FAR
CRY: NEO DAWN.
♪ ♪
>> WE WERE JUST T KIDS WHEN THE
BOMBS DROPPED IN THE WORLD WENT
SHIT TO.
THEY SAID IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE END OF EVERYTHING..
BUT FOR US, IT WAS JUST THE
BEGINNINGG.
SURVIVING?
NO.
WE WERE BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS NEW WORLD HAD A LOT TO GIVE
AND WE TOOK IT ALL.
THAT'S HOW WE CAME OUTUT ON TOP.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT HERE.
THAT'S HOW WE FOUND YOU.
LISTEN HERE, RABBITS!
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND SOMETHIN
SOMETHING.
THE ONLY CURRENCY LEFT IN THIS
WORLD IS POWER.
WE ARERE GOING TO TAKE EVERYTHIG
FROM YOU, STARTING WITH YOUR
HOME.
IF WE CAN'T TAKE IT...
WE'LL BREAK IT.
♪ ♪
>> I LED US INTO THE NEW WORLD,
I THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD BE
GLORIOUS.
IAS WRONG.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: YOU CAN ALSO FIND
SPECIAL OFFERS OALL OUR
NOMINATED GAMES ACROSS XBOX LIVE
AND THE PLAYSTATION STORE SO
MAKE SURE TO CHECK YOUR FAVORITE
PLACE TO GET GAMES FOR SPECIAL
OFFERS.
RIGHT NOW, WE'VE GOT ANOTHER
WORLD PREMIERE, CHECK THIS OUT.
♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU A ARE?
WHO DO YOU THINK YOU'RE E TALKIG
TO?
NOBODY CAN ENTER MY DOMAIN
WHETHER ALIVE OR DEAD.
YOU WISH TO LEARN THE HARD
WAY -- FINE.
THEN GO, GET OUT..
DON'T LET ME STOP YOU.
>> WASN'T PLANNING ON IT, FATHE
FATHER.
♪ ♪
>> I'M HOME.
TIME TO GO GET KILLED AGAIN.
♪ ♪
♪ ♪>> DEATH IS YOUR ONLY FAMILY.
DEATH AND UTTER
I.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: CONGRATULATIONS TWO
GUYS FROM SUPERGIANT, THAT IS A
TITLE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW ON THE
EPIC GAMES STORE.
I AM HERE NOW WITH MY FRIEND
PATRICE, T DESIGNER BEHIND
ASSASSIN'S CREED FAMOUSLY AND
YOU'RE WORKING ON A NEW PROJECT
CALLED ANCESTORS, HUMANKIND
ODYSSEY TELL US ABOUT THIS GAME.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME TO BE HERE.
I'M WORKING ON ANCESTORS, I IS
A SINGLE PLAYER OPEN WORLD
EXPLORATION SURVIVAL GAME, SET
IN AFRICATARTING 10 MILLION
YEARS AGO WHERE PLALAYERS WILL
PLAY THE LAST ANCESTORS OF THE
BIG APES OF LUCY.
>> Geoff: TELL US WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE TONIGHT, YOU'RE
GOING TO SHOW SOMOME GAMEPLAY,
RIGHT?
>> IT'S BY Y DIGITAL GAMES BACKN
MONTREAL, 30 PEOPLE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW FOUR CLIPS OF
ACTUAL GAMEPLAY, ME PLAYING LAST
WEEK.
>> Geoff: THIS IS REAL, ON THE
STICKS.
>> IF PEOPLE LIKE WHAT THEHEY S,
THEY CAN GO ON GAMESPOT AND SEE
ANOTHER 20 MINUTES OF ME PLAYING
THE VERY BEGINNG OF THE GAME
AFTER THE SHOW.
>>>> Geoff: HERE IS, ANCESTORS,
HUMANKIND ODYSSEY.
♪ ♪
>> GAMES PLAY BEST ON XBOX ONE.
>> IT'S A PROGRAM THAT INSPIRES
GIRLS TO MAKE GAMES, IT TEACHES
THEM TOOLS THEY NEED TO GET A
START WHERE THEY KNOW NOTHING TO
GET TO DEVELOP A FULL PROTOTYPE
IN THREE WEEKS.
>> MY FAVORITE PART ABOUT CAMP,
DOING THE DESIGNINING OF HOW THE
PLATFORM IS.
>> MY EXPIENCE HAS GIVEN ME
THE CONFIDENCE TO PURSUE O OTHER
WRITING AND VIDEO GAME PROJECTS.
>> THE WHOLE MISSION IS JUST
AMAZAZING, TO INSPIRE YOUNG GIRS
TO MAKE GAMES AND TO GET THE
FEMALE PERSPECTIVE AND VOICE IN
GAMES.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>>eoff: WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE
GAME AWARDS TO COME, HERE'S
ANOTHER WORLD PREMIERE.
♪ ♪
♪♪ ♪
♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: THAHAT'S YOUR FIRST
LOOK AT SCAVENGERERS, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR STUDIO.
>> MIDWINTER IS A NEW STUDIO O N
SEATTLE, WASHINGTON, WE ARE A
SMALL TEAM JUST OVER 20 PEOPLE.
MANY OF US COME FROM AAA
BACKGROUND, WORKING ON TITLES
LIKE HALO AND BATTLEFIELD AND
THIS IS OUR FIRST GAME IS A NEW
STUDIO
WE WENT WE GOT A TEASE OF THE
WORLD, WHAT KIND OF GAME IS AT?
>> IT'S A SURVIVAL SHOOTER
COOPERATIVE.
TEAMS NEED TO COOPERATE TO
SURVIVE BUCOMPETE TO WIN.
ALL THE ASPECTS OF A SURVIVAL
GAME AND CONDENSE IT INTO A
REPLACEABLE SESSION BASED
MULTIPLAYER EXPERIENCE.
>> Geoff: IF PEOPLE WANT TO
LEARN MORE THIS ATTACK TO SIGNU.
>> WERE GOING TO BE HAVING PLAY
TESTS AND PEOPLE CAN GO TO
SCAVENGERS GAME AND YOU'LL BE
AMONG THE FIRST TO PLAY
SCAVENGERS.
>> Geoff: IT'S AN AMAZING
WORLD PREMIERE FIRST LOOK AT
SCAVENGERS, SIGN UP FOR THAT
NOW.
IT'S NOW TIME TO PRESENT OUR
NEXT AWARD AND PLEASE WELCOME
THE FRONT MAN FROM PANIC AT THE
DISCO TO DO IT, BRANDON YURI!
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND D APPLAUSE]
>> I WANT TO SAY WHAT AN HONOR
IT IS TO BE HERE AND SECONDLY I
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I WAS
SUPPOSED TO WRITE SOMETHING LAST
NIGHT BUT I STAYED UP UNTIL
5:00 A.M. PLAYING "FORTNITE"
."
THEY WROTE IT FOR ME.
PERSONALLY AS A MUSICIAN I'M
CONSTANTLY AMAZED BY THE SKILLS
OF THE COMPOSERS IN THIS
INDUSTRY, THEY MAKE TRACKS THAT
ELEVATE ALL THE ACTION AND
TENSION AND SET THE PERFECT
MOOD.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES.
>> BEST SCORE/MUSIC PRESENTED BY
SPARTA FIVE.
SPOT IF.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> OKAY, THE AWARD GOES TO "RED
DEAD REDEMPTION 2".
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> THANKS.
I WASN'T EXPECTING IT THANKS A
LOT.
THANKS TO MY WIFE, SHARON
JACKSON, MY TWO DAUGHTERS,
GEORGIA WASHINGTON JACKSON AND
THEODORE ROOSEVELT JACKSON, MAKE
SURE I GET THAT OUT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE MY FAMILY.
I'M NOT A COMEDIAN BUT I TRY TO
PLAY ONE SOMETETIMES.
ROCK STAR, MY SURROGATE FAMILY
THANK U SO MUCH.
AND THIS GUY CAME IN AND DID THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL, SAD MUSIC.
ALL RIGHT, MY BROTHER.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: CONGRATULATIONS TO
THEM.
SPEAKING OF SOUNDTRACK, I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW I'VE GOT A NEW
PODCAST WITHH SPOTIFY, WE
INTERVIEWED THEM, SO LOTS OF
GREAT STUFF, MAKE SURE TO CHECK
THAT OUT TONIGHT ON SPOTIFY.
RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
SOME OTHER WINNERS TONIGHT AND
OTHER MAJOR CATEGORIES.
THE BEST AUDIO DESIGN PRESENTED
BY DOLBY, THESE ARE THE
NOMINEES.
"CALL OF DUTY" BLACK OPS FOUR.
"FORZA HORIZON 4" 4.
GOD OF W, "MARVEL'S
SPIDER-MAN," AND RED DEAD THE RD
REDEMPTION
"RED DEAD
REDEMPTION 2".
ART DIRECTION, ASSASSIN'S CREED
ODYSSEY, "GOD OF WAR," OCTOPATH
TRAVELER, "RED DEAD REDEMPTION
2" AND "RETURN OF THE OBRA DINN
DINN."
AND THE WINNER IS "RETURN OF THE
OBRA DINN"
."
CONGRATULATIONS.
NEXT UP, CATEGORY BEST MOBILE
GAME AND THOSE NOMINEES ARE
DOUGHNUT COUNTY, FLORENCE,
"FORTNITE"
," "PUBG MOBILE," AND
"REIGN GAME OF THRONES."
THE AWARD FOR BEST MOBILE GAME
GOES TO "FLORENCE."
BEST VR GAME, THOSE NOMINEES ARE
ASKED ROBOT RESCUE MISSION.
BEAT SABER, FIREWALL ZERO HOUR,
MOSS, AND TESTER
TETRIS EFF.
ASKED ROBOT IS THE WINNER.
CONTENT CREATOR OF THE YEAR IS
COMING UP AND LET'S SEE WHAT THE
TWITCH POLL IS PREDICTING, IT
LOOKS LIKE PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING
THAT NINJA IS GOING TO WIN THAT
ONE WITH 49% OF THE VOTE.
WE'LL FIND OUT, HE'S IN THE
HOUSE ALONG WITH MANY Y OTHER
CONTENT CREATORS.
WAR FRAME HAS HAD ITS BIGGEST
YEAR YET, IT JUST LAUNCHED FOR
TWO NOT THE NEWEST OPEN WORLD
EXPANSION ON PC AND IT'S COMING
TO XBOX AND PS FOUR ON
DECEMBER 10TH.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER YOU CAN
PLAY WAR FRAME ANYWHERE ON THE
SWITCH.
HERE'S A LOOK AT WAR FRAME UP
FOR SWITCH.
♪ ♪
♪
>> I THOHT I KNEW WHY I CAME
HERE.
I SAW IT.
>> YOU SET THE APOCALYPSE IN
MOTION.
>> I WON'T LET THAT HAPPEN!
♪ ♪
>> IF YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
ALTER THE COURSE OF HUMANITY.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: I'M HERE WITH THE
GAME DIRECTOR OF DEAD BY
DAYLIGHT, WELCOME TO "THE GAME
AWARDS."
>> IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
>> Geoff: LOTS OF CANADIAN
MONTREAL TEAMS I LOVE TO SEE IN
MY HOME COUOUNTRY.
>> WE PLAN TO KEEP THIS GAMEME
ALIVE FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AND TO SHOW OUR
DEDICATION.
TONIGHT WE ARE ANNOUNCING THE
DEDICATED SERVERS ARE COMING TO
DEAD BY DAYLIGHT THIS SUMMER.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SHOW THE
TRAILER FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME,
DARKNESS AMONG US.
>> Geoff: ANOTHER WORLD
PREMIERE, THANKS SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: I'M BACK HERE NOW
WITH KATE C HUDSON THE MANAGER
OF MY AWARE.
WE'RE MOST DONE WITH ANTHEM,
TELL US WHERE YOU'RE AT.
>> THEY'RE DOING AN INCREDIBLE
JOB FINISHING IT UP, IT'S ALMOST
DONE.
WE ARE SUPER HAPPY TO BE HERE
AND SHOW MORE OF THE GAME.
>> Geoff: WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
SEE?
>> A LOT OF WHAT WE'VE SHOWN SO
FAR IS THE GAMEPLAY, SUPER FUN.
YOU'RE AN ARMORED SUPERHERO IN A
FANTASY SETTING, LOU SHOWED A
LOT OF THAT BUT WE HAVEN'T LET
PEOPLE IN ON WHAT THE STORY IS
IN THE CHARACTERS.
LIKE A GREAT BUY AWARE GAME,
WERE BUILDING UP A WHOLE WORLD
OF STORY AND THINGS WE NEED TO
DISCOVER.
WE ARE GOING TO START LETTING
YOUU IN ON A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THAT.
WE'VE GO A BIG TEAM WORKING ON
IT B WE HAVE A FEW PROJECTS
FROM BUY AWARE.
WE DO HAVE A FEW SURPRISES LEFT.
>> Geoff: ANTHEM RIGHT NOW.
>> ANTHEM RIGHT NOW AND ALWAYS
THINKING ABOUT OUR NEXT THING.
>> Geoff: HERE'S A LOOK AT
ANTHEM, CHECK IT OUT.
>> I HAVE SEEN THE POWER OF THE
ANTHEM
DESTROY ENTIRE CIVILIZATIONS.
>> YOU KNOW I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THE HEART COULD DO TO A PERSONN.
>> I FEEL THE NEW POWER.
>> THE JAVELINS ALLOWED US TO
FIGHT BACK THE CHAOS.
THE WALLS PROTECTED OUR
FAMILIES.
LOVED ONES.
>> REMEMBER, WE ARE A TEAM, I'M
RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
>> THIS IS A FREELANCER JOB,
ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
>> BUT THE ANTHEM STILL RAGES.
♪ ♪
>> OF THE WALLS CAN ONLY DO SO
MUCH.
BUT WITH THE POWER OF THE ANTHEM
ATAT MY FINGNGERTIPS, I LL ENDLL
THIS.
NEEDLESS SUFFERING.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: "THE GAME AWARDS"
CONTINUES,S, EVERYBODY IS HERE
TONIGHT INCLUDING CRASH
BANDICOOT, LET'S DO IT!
>> I THOUGHT YOU DESERVE A
TROPHY OF YOUR OWN.
>>>> Geoff: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
THIS IS THE STANDARD ISSUE CRASH
CREATE.
WHILE MATT, WHAT'S THIS?
THIS LOOKS FAMILIAR.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE WORLD
PREMIERE.
♪ ♪
>> PLEASE WELCOME CHRISTOPHER
JUDGE.
♪♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> GAMES HAVE ALWAYS HAD A
STRONG SENSE OF COMMUNITY.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A KID,
YOUNGER -- GATHERED AROUND
SOMEONE AT THE ARCADE, I WAS
CLOSE TO BREAKING A HIGH SCORE.
I WAS BWN AWAY BY HOW MUCH
BIGGER THAT COMMUNITY IS IN
TODAY'S CONNECTED AGE.
>> MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD AREN'T JUST PLAYING THE
GAMES THEY LOVE, THEY'RE EXTREM.
STREAM.
>>HESE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR
CONTENT CREATOR OF THE YEAR.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> THERE WE GO!
>> IT'S SOMETHING I ENJOY, BEING
ABLE TO BRING JOY TO OTHERS
DOING SOMETHING YOU ENJOY IS A
MIRACLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND THE GAME AWARD GOES TO,
READ IT, BOY.
>> THE AWARD G GOES TO NINJA.
♪ ♪
>> THI HONOR.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK MY
LOVELY WIFE JESSICA W WHO IS
JOINING ME E TODAY AND MY FAMILY
WHO'S SUPPORTING ME MY ENTIRE
LIFE, TY'VE ALWAYS LET ME PLAY
VIO GAMES AS LONG AS I WAS
JUST A LITTLE B BIT MORE ACTIVE
OUTSIDE.
THIS HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE YEAR
FOR GAMING AND VEO GAMES, I'M
HONESTLY BLESSED TO BE IN THE
POSITION THAT I'M INN TO BRING
JOY TO ALL THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE
WATCHING VEO GAMES.
I THINK IT'S CRAZY THAT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN N THIS ROOM AND
EVY SINGLE PERSON WATCHING,
IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF VIDEO GAMAM.
HERE'S TO ANOTHER INCREDIBLE
YEAR, THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH, I
APPRECIATE IT.
>> FROM OBSIDIA PLEASE WELCOME
THE CREATOR AND GAME DESIGNER OF
FALLOUT.
>> IT'S HA TO BELIEVE IT'S
BEEN 20 YEARS SINCE WE MADE
FALLOUT.
>> IT'S GREAT T TO BE UNITED ONA
NEW SINGLE PLAYER RPG, WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO REVEAL OUR
BRAND-NEW GAME AND A BRAND-NEW
UNIVERSE THE OUTER WORLD.
>> YOU WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO SAY
THAT, REMEMBER?
>> WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSESED TO SAY
IS BY WATCHING THIS TRAILER, YOU
ARE LEGALLY OBLIGATED TO ENJOY
IT.
♪ ♪
>> THERE YOU ARE, WONDERING
WH'S GOING ON.
ARE YOU FEELING ANYTHING THAT
COULD BE CONSTRUED AS EXPLOSIVEE
CELL DEATH?
♪ ♪
WELCOME TO THE EDGE OF THE
GALAXY, THE FRONTIER OF SPACE.
AT LEAST IT WAS UNTIL THEHE
RPORATIONS BRANDED IT AND
STARTED SELLING IT AT THE
DICROUSLY INFLATED PRICES.
THE REST OF YOUR FELLOW SETTLERS
ABANDONED ON THE EDGE OF THE
COLONNADE.
I'D VE THEM MYSELF BUT THE
BOARD HAS A BOUNTY ON MY HEAD.
SO, THAT'S WHY I THAWED YOU OUT,
YOU APPEAR CAPABLE.
>> I GET IT.
TAKING ON THE CORPOTION HAS
LEFT US WITH TWO CHOICES.
BAD AND WORSE.
YOHAVE TO COSE AND YOU HAVE
TO CHOOSE NOW.
YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
SHOOT EITHER ONE, RIGHT?
BUT IT'S FINE I GUESS, YOU JUST
KEEP BEING YOU.
♪ ♪
♪
>> NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
FEELING OF VERTIGO YOU MAY FEEL
BY WATCHING THIS ADVERTISEMENT.
>> THAT'S THE BRAND-NEW TITLE,
THANKS FOR THAT.
CHECK OUT THIS.
♪ ♪
♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: THE CEO OF PHOENIX
LABS, A COUPLE YEARS AGO YOU
WERE WITH US ANNOUNCING THIS
GAME AND NOW YOU'RE BACK.
>> WE SURE ARE AND IT'S BEEN
QUITE THE COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED TO NOT ONLY
TALK ABOUT THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS BUT ALSO THE FUTURE.
IT'S AWESOME COMING INTO THE
FUTURE AND BEIEING ABLE TO SEE D
LAUNCH THE GAME ON XBOX AND PS4,
THEY HAVE THAT PLATFORM FROM THE
GET-GO, DAUNTLESS HAS ALWAYSS
BEEN ABOUT BRINGING PLAYERS
TOGETHER WITH YOUR FRIENDS AND
KILLING BIG BEHEMOTHS, THOSE
PLATFORMS AREOING TO BEHE
NEXT BIG JOURNEY FOR US.
IT'S OUR BIGGEST CONTENT
EXPANSION PACK, DRO TODAY ON
PC.
>> Geoff: WILL PLAY DAUNTLESS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK AFTER THIS.
>> WHEN I WAS GROWING UP, THERE
WASN'T MUCH EXPECTATIONSROM
GIRLS.
I'M FROM A VERY HUMBLE
BACKGROUND, IT WASIFFICULT FOR
ME TO PURSUE THIS, TO MAKE
MONEY, TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
SCHOOL SO I COULD STUDY COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
IT'S NOT JUST GETTING A DEGREE.
THAT'S WHAT  WANT
TOEE WHAT KIND OF IDEAS CAN
CONNECT PEOPLE WE H HAVE IN
PAKISTAN.
>> COMING UP, JOEL MIKAEL
RECOGNIZES BT eSPORTS PLAYER
AND A MUSICAL PERFORMANCECE OF
DODOUBLERIGGER.
LATER, AN EXCXCITING ANNOUNUNCET
FROM FORT KNIGHT.
THIS IS "THE GAME AWARDS"
."
♪ ♪
>> SUPER SMASH BROTHERS ULTIMAT
ULTIMATE.
I HOPE YOU HAVE THE STAMINA
BECAUSE THE GAME IS ABOUT TO BE
IN STOCKCK.
>>ELCOME TO MY STORE.
IT'S ONE NOT BOUND BY RULES.
OR LIMITED BY INVENTORY.
OR RESTRICTETED BY TIME.
THE ONLY RULE HERE IS TO
UNTETHERED YOUR IGINATION AND
UNLEASH IT.
>> ♪ ♪
♪ ♪♪
>> TONIGHT WE'VE GOT SOMOME OF E
BIGGEST FRANCHISES IN THE WORLD
UNVEILING THEIR GAMES WE ALSO
HAVE SMALLER STUDIOS SHARING
THEIR PROJECTS.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
SURPRISES.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> NOW HERE IS ACTOR CODIAN
JOEL MIKAEL.
MCHALE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU HAVE MEB.
WHEN I WAS ASKED TO PRESENT THE
AWARD FOR BEST eSPORTS PLAYER,
I DID NOT HESITATE.
VIDEO GAMES HAVE BROUGHT ME AND
MY SONS CSER TOGETHER.
EVERY MORNING THEY FIRE UP ----
SHOCKER -- FORT KNIGHT AND THEIR
EYES LIGHT UP WITH THE PROMISE
OF A NEW DAY AND THEY DEMAND MY
CREDIT CARD INFORMATION.
TO PURCHCHASE A MERMAN SKIN AND
DAY-GLO ACTS.
IT SEEMS LIKE ONLY YESTERDAY
THEY WERE FORCING ME TO BUY A
RAINBOW WRITER, THEY GROW UP SO
FAST.
I'M OKAY.
eSPORTS CONTINUE TO GROW
EXPONTIALLY EVERY YEAR WITH
SOLD-OUT ANA TOURNAMENTS ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THE LININE, THIS AWAD
RECOGNIZES THE MOST DOMINANT
ATHLETE IN THE SPOS.
WHOEVER WINS THIS IS BASICALLY
THE LeBRON JAMES OF SITTING.
IT'S AMAZINGNG.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEESS.
>> BEST eSPORTS PLAYER,
PRESENTED BY OHMAN BY HPHP.
>> THIS KID CAN DO IT, CAN
TAKE IT ALL.
>> SONICFOFOX IS A CHAMP!
IS A
>> WHAT A YEAR FOR THE BET
PLAYER IN THE WORLD.
>> THAT IS STUNNINGLY SIMPLE.
>> STY FROM JJONAK.
>>>> THE GAME ARD GOES T
SOCFOX.
♪ ♪ HEAVY.
IF YOU'VE GOT ANY EARPLUGS, I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO THROW THEM
AWAY.
IF YOU HAVE ANY RELIGIOUS
ARTIFACTS COME UP THOSE AWAY,
TOOK YOU UNDER YOUR SEATS
BECAUSE WE ARE ABOUT TO SUMMON
SOME START SPIRITS HERE IS THE
COMPOSER OF DEVIL MAY CRY FIVE
PERFORMING DEVIL TRIGGER!
♪ ♪
>> THERE IT WAS, OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS NEARLY 20 MILLION
PLAYERS HAVE TRAINED DINOSAURS
IN THE EPIC ARK SURVIVAL
EVOLVED.
A GIGANTIC WORLD OF EXPLORATION
AND CONQUEST, TAKE A LOOK.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: I'M HERE WITH JEREMY
AND JESSE FROM WILD CARD
STUDIOS.
COMING NEXT WEEK, WHAT EXACTLY
IS ATLAS?
>> IT'S A MASSIVE OPEN WORLD
SURVIVAL AND MEMO, 40,000
CONCURRENT PLAYERS IN THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING AN ARMADA,
CLAIMING TERRITORY, FORMING AN
EMPIRE AND ULTIMATELY DOMINATING
THE ENTIRE GLOBE, IT'S A HUGE
SCALE.
>> Geoff:OW BIG IS THE MAP?
>> IT'S FOUR TIMES THE SIZE OF A
SINGLE ART SERVER AND OUR TEAM
HAS SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
HANDCRAFTED BEAUTIFUL PLACES TO
PLAY IN.
WE FILLED IT WITH AMAZING
CREATURES, EVERYTHING FROM
THINGS YOU WOULD EXPECT LIKE
LIVESTOCK TO CRAZY MYTHOLOGICAL
CREATURES THAT ARE GUARDING THE
SESECRETS OF AN ANCIENT
CIVILIZATION -- THERE'S SO MUCH
FUN STUFF TO SEE AND DO, IT'S
GOING  BE AWESOME TO ENGAGE IN
IN.
>> Geoff: COMING TO PC, ANY
WORD COMING TO CONSOLE?
>> IT WILL BE COMING TO CONSOLE
ON XBOX, WE GOT GREAT FEEDBACK
FROM FANS AND WE ARE EXCITED TO
BRING IT TO XBOX NEXT YEAR.
>> Geoff: THANKS, A LOT OF
WORK -- WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WE'VE GOT OUR TWITCH POLL
CONTINUING.
TWITCH THINKS "DEAD CELLS" IS
GOING TO TAKE THE AWARD FOR BEST
INDEPENDENT GAME.
>> ON THE WAY, A WORLD PREMIERE
YOU WON'T WANT TO MISS.
WE PRESENT THE AWARD FOR BEST
INDEPENDENT GAME AND LATER WE
CELEBRBRATE THE MUSIC OF "RED DD
REDEMPTION 2", DON'T STOP
STREAMING, THIS IS "THE GAME
AWARDS"
"
♪ ♪
>> YOU'VE GOT TO STEP IT UP,
YOUR SUIT GAME NEEDS TO BE
TIGHT.
LOOK AT ME, MAN!
TITER.
REALLY?
>> MY MAN!
DRESSED TO KILL.
>> JOIN US TODAY.
>> IT'S GREAT FOR US NOT ONLY
FOR THE GAME BUT FOR US AS A
RACE.
>> IN THE TELEVISION SERIES THE
OUTPOST I PLAY A NIGHT CAPTAIN
AND AN ELDERCROLLS ONLINE I
PLAY A MAGICAL.
>> I PLAY ON IMPERIAL TANK IN
ELDER SCROLLS ONLINE.
>> I PLAYED A RED GUARD TO STEM
A DRAGON NIGHT, EVEN THOUGH MY
BROTHER HAS BEEN TOO BUSY TO
PLAY WITH ME RECENTLY.
>> Geoff: WELCOME BACK TO "THE
GAME AWARDS" WE HAVE SO MUCH,
MORE COMING FOR YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO AOUNCE OTHER
WINNERS ACROSS CATEGORIES, THE
NOMINEES FOR BEST DEBUT INDIE
GAME, MAKING ITS FIRST PROJECT,
THE MESSENGER -- IN THE GAME
AWARD GOES TO THE MESSENGER.
ALSO A CANADIAN STUDIO.
NEXT UP, BEST FIGHTING GAME
THOSE NOMINEES THIS YEAR ARE
DRAGON BALL FIGHTERS, SOUL
CALIBER SIX, STREETFIGHTER 5,
AND THE WINNER FOR BEST BEST
FIGHTING GAME, DRAGON BALL
FIGHTERS.
THE BEST FAMILY GAME THE
NOMINATORS THIS YEAR ARE MARIO
TENNIS ACES, NINTENDO LABO,
STARLIKE BATTLE FOR ATLAS AND
SUPER MARIO PARTY.
IN THE GAME AWARD GOES TO
OVERCOOKED 2.
ANOTHER GENRE CATEGORY FOR BEST
STRATEGY GAME.
THE BANNER SAGA THREE, BATTLE
TECH, FROST PUNK, "INTO THE
BREACH" AND CHRONICLES FOUR, THE
WINNER FOR BEST STRATEGY GAME,
"INTO THEE BREACH"
."
WE'VE GOT A LOT MORE SHOW AHEAD
FOR YOU TONIGHT AND WE'VE GOT
THE BIG AWARDS WE'VE T TO THE
BEST GAME DIRECTION, GAME OF THE
YEAR AND SO MUCH MORE.
RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT
ANOTHER GAME ANNOUNCEMENT WORLD
PREMIERE.
IS IT A MUSICAL
♪ ♪
>> SO YOU FOUND ME AT LAST.
I SUSPECT YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CONGRATULATIONS MY FRIEND ON
THE BIG WIN.
LET ME GET A SELFIE.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S A GOO SELFIE.
>> DID YOU JUST SAY SHELF?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: WE'VE GOT MUCH MORE
SHOW TO COME, WE'VE GOT A MUPPET
ON THE SHOW FINALLY, I'M VERY
PERSONALLY HAPPY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU CAN FIND A SPECIAL OFFERS ON
ALL THE NOMINATED GAMES ACROSS
NINTENDO, XBOX -- OF COURSE WE
ARE TRENDING NUMBER ONE
WORLDWIDE ON TWITTER, I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR TALKING ABOUT
THE SHOW, SEE SOME OF THESE
AMAZING TWEETS.
VERY EXCITING STUFF.
THERE'S ANOTHER GAME LAUNCHING
TONIGHT ITS HUMAN HEAD'S NEW
GAME SURVIVED BY, IT'S LAUNCHING
RIGHT W ON STEAM.
YOU CAN PLAY EARLY ACCESS AND
IT'S PUBLISHED BY DIGITAL
EXTREME, THE DEVELOPERS OF WAR
FRAME.
HERE'S A FIRST LOOK.
>>>> SOMETHING DARK HAS EMERGED
FROM THE DEPTHS OF THE EARTH.
CHANGING EVEN THE CUTE AND
CUDDLY, TO THE AND DEADLY.
IT IS UP TO YOU TO BUILD YOUR
ARSENAL.
AND SET FORTH ON AN EPIC
JOURNEY.[BLEEP] ♪ ♪
IT IS NOW UP TO YOU -- AND
PROBABLY MANY MORE OF YOU TO SET
FORTH ON AN EPIC JOURNEY TO
DEFEAT THIS SPREADING FLAKE THAT
SOURS ON LAND.
TEAM UP WITH FRIENDS, AND TACKLE
MENACING FOES, OR GO IT ALONE.
YOU CAN TRY, IT'S
>> Geoff: I'M HERE WITH ELAINE
CHASE THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
ESPORTRTS FOR MAGIC THE
GATHERING, SOME FUN CAMEOS IN
THAT PIECE.
WHAT WILL THE WORLD KNOW?
>> I AM SO EXCITED TO BE HERE
TONIGHT TO ANNOUNCE MAGIC THE
GATHERING'S NEW COMPETITIVE
GAMING PROGRAM.
IN 2019 WE HAVE $10 MILLION IN
PRIZE MONEY ACROSS DIGITAL AND
TABLETOP MAGIC.
>> Geoff: BIG PRIZE, ONE IS IT
GOING TO START?
>> AT ALL KICKS OFF IN MARCH AT
PAX IN BOSTON WERE HOSTING ONE
MILLION-DOLLAR INVITATIONAL.
>> Geoff: HOW DO PEOPLE GET ON
BOARD?
DOWNLOAD AND START PLAYING, I'VE
GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL FOR THE
AUDIENCE.
IF YOU USE THE CODE GAME AWARDS
YOU'LL RECEIVE AN eSPORTS
STARTER KIT WITH SOME AWESOME
CARDS TO PLAY.
>> Geoff: THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE MAGIC PART OF
THE GAME AWARDS.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE SHOW TO COME
UP TONIGHT, A WINNER TONIGHT FOR
A BUNCH OF AWARDS, "RED DEA
REDEMPTION 2" CREATED A NEW
STANDARD AMONG BEAUTIFUL
LANDSCAPES METICULOUS DETAIL TO
ITS WORLD.
THERE IS ALSO BRILLIANT SCORE
THAT TRANSPORTED US STRAIG TO
AMERICA IN 1829.
HERE ARE A PAIR OGRAMMY AWARD
WINNERS, ENJOY.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE WANT T TO THANK THE BAND R
THAT AMAZING PERFORMANCE, IT'T'S
ALWAYS A THRILL FOR ME, I THINK
WE'VE DID IT BETTER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
LET'S TAKE A TRIP BACK TO
HAWKINS INDIANA.
>> WE GOING TO DO THIS?
LET'S ENGAGE
♪ ♪
>> PLEASWELCOME THE CREATORS
OF THE NETFLIX STREAMING
PHENOMENON STRANGER THINGS.
>> THANK YOU GUYS, IT IS VERY
COOL TO BE HERE, WE WERE SIX
YEARS OLD WHEN WE RECEIVED A
BRAND-NEW SYSTEM CALLED NINTENDO
FOR CHRISTMAS, WE'VE BEEN
GAINING EVER SINCE.
WE THINK IT'S BEEN PARTICULARLY
AN INCREDIBLE YEAR FOR GAMES
WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE FOR NETFLIX
BECAUSE PLAYING YOUR GAMES HAS
PROBABLY DELAYED OUR RELEASE BY
A MONTH AT L LEAST FOR SURURE.
COME ON, IT'S INCREDIBLE.
WE ARE GLAD WE COULD BE HERE
TONIGHT TO ANNOUNCE A NEW
STRANGER THINGS VIDEO GAME, IT
FOLLOWS THE EVENTS OF SEASON
THREE WITH A FEW SURPRISES OF
ITS OWN AND YOU CAN PLAY CO-OP
ON XBOX, SWITCH, AND PC.
WE'VE MADE A BIG GRAPHICAL LEAP,
WE ARE UP TO 16 BITS.
WATCH OUT ROCK STAR, TAKE A LOO
LOOK.
♪ ♪
>> HE IS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AT ANOTHER REALM STUDIOS AND THE
CREATOR OF MORTAL KOMBAT AND
INJUSTICE.
>> THANK YOU, IT'S GREAT TO BE
BACK HERE AT THE GAME AWARDS
IT'S MY HONOR TONIGHT TO PRESENT
THE AWARD FOR BEST SPORTS OR
RACING GAME, LET'S CHECK OUT THE
NOMINEES.
>> BEST SPORTS-RACING GAME.
♪ ♪
♪♪
>> GET OVER HERE!
♪ ♪
>> SORRY ABOUT THAT, I THINK
THEY PLAYED THE WRONG VIDEO.
HERE ARE THE REAL NOMINEES FOR
BEST SPORTS-RACING GAME.
>> BEST SPORTS-RACING GAMEE.
♪ ♪
THE GAME AWARD G GOES TO FORCE A
HORIZON 4
>> WHAT A VISIONARY LEGEND.
ED BOONE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY PEOPLE
WORKING ON THE FORZA FRANCHISE,
IT'S A HUGE HONOR TO ACCEPT THIS
ON THEIR BEHALF.
"FORZA HORIZON 4" HAS NOW BEEN
OUR BEST GAME.
IT'S BEEN AN INCREDIBLE HONOR TO
WATCH.
THE TEAM IS WORKING REALLY HARD
AS YOU SAW, WE HAVE A WHOLE NEW
UPDATE COMING ON DECEMBER 13TH
AND WE ARE JUST GETTING STARTED,
THANK YOU.
♪ ♪
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
BOY.
>> IS IT ME?
>> SAVE YOUR QUESTIONS UNTIL THE
END RASPUTIN.
>> HE WAS A UNIQUELY TALENTED
ACROBAT BUT ALSO A GIFTED
PSYCHIC.
HE WAS A BIG PAIN IN THE NECK
BUT SOMEBODY MESSED UP AND LET
HIM INTO THE CYCLE
PSYCHONAU.
THIS 10-YEAR-OLD CIRCUS RUNAWAY
WAS SOMEHOW LET IN TO JOIN THE
PSYCHIC SUPER SPIES AND NOW HE'S
RIGHT INTO THE MOTHER LODE.
>> MAN, YOU GUYS REALLY LIKE
PALMS.
>> BUT HE BETTER WISE UP, THIS
IS NO SUMMER CAMP.
THE MOTHER LODE HAS ITS OWN WAY
OF DOING THINGS.
ITS FAIR SHARE OF DANGEROUS,
HIDDEN SECRETS -- IF THEY EVER
GOT OUT, THINGS WOULD NEVER BE
THE SAME FOR THE PSYCHONAUTS
PERIOD THEIR FRIENDS, THEIR
FAMILY, THERE ARE THOUGHTS THATD
NEVER BE OPENED.
SOME BRANDS ARE BETTER OFF LEFT
BROKEN.
>> I WON'T DO ANYTHING CRAZY.
>> WHATEVER YOU DO, LEAVE ME OUT
OF IT.
>> IS THAT HONEY PEPPER BACON?
[APPLAUSE]
>> FIRST ANNOUNCED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO, WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT
YEAR.
I'M NOW JOINED BY PHIL SPENCER,
WE SAW YOU AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW.
>> YOU DESERVE CREDIT FOR
PUTTING THAT MOMENT TOGETHER, I
THINK IT'S GREAT TO SHOW THE
INDUSTRY COMING TOGETHER AND
JEFF DID THAT, CONGRATS ON THAT.
>> IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE ALL
OF US HERE, WE LOVE GAMES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT XBOX IT'S BEEN
A BIG YEAR FOR XBOX, HOW HAS 18
BEEN GOING FOR YOU?
>> WE HAD A PRETTY GOOD YEAR, WE
CAN DO BETTER, WE ADDED SOME
STUDIOS, STATE OF DECAY, FORZA
HORIZON 4, WE HAVE THE ADAPTIVE
CONTROLLER THIS LAST YEAR
SOMETHING I'M VERY PROUD OF.
IT'S BEEN A GOOD YEAR AND NEWS
COMING ABOUT XBOX, ATLAS COMING
NEXT YEAR TO GET A PREVIEW.
>> WE HAVE A LONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH STUDIO WILD CARD, ONE OF
OUR EARLIER TEAMS, ALWAYS TRYING
TO BUILD PROGRAMS TO HELP
DEVELOPERS.
ALL OF THESE THINGS JUST TO HELP
DEVELOPERS REACH AS MANY GAMERS
AS POSSIBLE.
>> Geoff: SPEAKING OF GAME
PASS LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT, WHAT
CAN YOU TELL US?
EVERYTHING IS COMING TO GAME
PASS.
>> WE HAD PEOPLE PLAYING THAT
GAME THIS WEEK, WE ARE LAUNCHING
RIGHT NOW IN TWO GAME PASS, IT'S
INCREDIBLE.
ALL OF THOSE IN GAME PASS, ALL
OF OUR WINTER OF ARCADE.
IT LAUNCHING BOTH SALE, GET AS
MANY GAME PASS AS YOU CAN.
WE'VE GOT TO CRACK DOWN 3, WERE
GOING TO BE WATCHING THAT.
WE'VE GOT GEARS 5, I WILL BE
INCREDIBLE.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE FRANCHISES
COME OUT IN THIS GENERATION,
SEEING THE NEXT ORIE COME OUT.
THIS YEAR WAS AN AWESOME YEAR
FORMAT GAMERS AND I LOOK AT IT
NEXT YEAR IT'S LINED UP TO BE
ANOTHER BETTER YEAR.
>> Geoff: DEVIL MAY CRY, WE
SAW THE PERFORMANCE OF DEVIL
TRIGGER.
>> PEOPLE DON'T KNOW DEVIL MAY
CRY, IT'S LAUNCHING ITS BETA
TOMORROW ON XBOX SO PEOPLE CAN
GO OUT AND PLAY.
DEVIL MAY CRY ON XBOX TOMORROW,
PEOPLE CAN SEE THE CRAZY IN THAT
GAME IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
>> Geoff: IT'S COMING FIRST TO
XBOX, RIGHT?
WILL CHECK IT OUT, GREAT TO HAVE
YOU HERE AT "THE GAME AWARDS" WE
HOPE TO HAVE YOU HERE NEXT YEAR,
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
BRAND-NEW STUFF FROM DEVIL MAY
CRY.
>> I WILL SHOW YOU YOUR WORST
NIGHTMARE.
>> I MUST DESTROY.
TIME TO KICK SOME ASS.
>> WHEN YOU TELL ME EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS JOB?
>> A POWERFUL DEMON IS ABOUT TO
RESURRECT AND WE NEED YOUR HELP,
DANTE.
>> D DEVIL MAY CRY.
>> GAMES PLAY BEST ON XBOX ONE.
HIS MUSICAL >> IT'S NOT EASY.
ARE YOU GOING TO LIVE TOMORROW?
I ASKED MY MOM TO BUY FOR ME A
COMPUTER, SHE SAVED MONEY FOR
THREE YEARS.
IT WAS THAT MOMENT, EVERYTHING
IS POSSIBLE FOR ME.
I DECIDED TO TEACH MYSELF
PROGRAMMING.
I MADE A GAME CALLED SALAM, AN
ARABIC WORD MEANING PEACE.
I HAVE THE PASSION AND ABILITY
TO CHANGE THE WORLD AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
>> TO PRESENT THE AWARD FOR BEST
GAME DIRECTION, LATER DIRECTING
DUO OTHERS ASSEMBLE ON STAGE
AND MORE MUSIC FROM "THE GAME
AWARDS" ORCHESTRA, "THE GAME
AWARDS" WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪ ♪
>> IN THE BEGINNING, THERE WAS
NOTHING.
THEN THERE WAS LIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> SHE'S A MEMBER OF "THE GAME
AWARDS" ORCHESTRA TONIGHT.
>> AS DEMONSTRATED TONIGHT,
GAMES REQUIRE HUNDREDS OF
ELEMENTS FROM MUSIC AND ART TO
ACTING, WRITING, PROGRAMMING,
AND DESIGN.
GREAT DIRECTION IS EVIDENT WHEN
THE WORK OF HUNDREDS SOMEHOW
COMBINES INTO A UNIFIED CREATE
VISION.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
GAME DIRECTION.
>> BEST GAME DIRECTION.
♪ ♪
>> I DIDN'T CHOOSE TO BE
DIFFERENT.
>> IT'S MORE THAN UNFORGIVING.
IT'S NO PLACE FOR A BOY.
>> HELLO NEW YORK!
NEXT TIME LEAVE THE FIGHTING TO
THE PROS.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO KILL ANY OF
YOU.
BUT WE WILL.
>> THE GAME AWARD GOES TO...
"GOD OF WAR"
."
>> "GOD OFF WAR" ALSO WINS FOR
BEST ACTION ADVENTURE GAME.
♪ ♪
>> WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
SON OF A BITCH, I'M NOT GOING TO
CRY TONIGHT.
I'D LIKE TO THINK SONY, FOR THE
SUPPORT AND FAITH YOU FOOLISHLY
PLACED IN ME AND MY GREAT TEAMM
OVER AT SANTA MONICA, TO MY
AMAZING WIFE.
MY SON, MY INSPIRATION THROUGH
ALL OF THIS TO THE UNBELIEVABLE
TEAM THAT I'VE BEEN BLESSED WIT
WITH.
EVERY HUMAN BEING THAT PUT SO
MUCH OF THEMSELVES.
I'M FOREVER THANKFUL FOR ALL OF
YOU AND ALL OF THE WORK COME UP
FROM CAST, BEYOND WHAT WE EVER
COULD IMAGINE.
TO DAVID JOFFE WHO CREATED THIS
I WOULDN'T EVEN BE HERE IF HE
HADN'T DONE THAT.
2018 HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTELY
BANANAS YEAR FOR GAMES.
WE ARE ALL LUCKY THAT EVERY
GREAT CREATOR OUT THERE, ERY
CREATOR IN THIS AUDIENCE AND
AROUND THE WORLD IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUSHING IT.
MOTIVATING ME AND EVERYBODY ELS
TO WORK EVEN HARDER BUT IT
WOULDN'T BE WORTH IT -- WE
WOULDN'T BE DRIVEN WITHOUT ALL
OF THE FANS OUT THERE.
WITHOUT ALL THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE
GAMES, ALL GAMES,, ALL THROUGHOT
THE INDUSTRY.
WE HAVE AN AMAZING COMMUNITY AND
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT UNITES
US THAHAN DIVIDES US, SO
THANK YOU, E EVERYBODY,
.
♪ ♪
♪
>> HE'S HAD A BUSY DAY BUT HERE
HE IS ON "THE GAME AWARDS" STAGE
COME ON DONALD.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON SUCH AN
INSANE YEAR.
>> IT'S BEEN A CRAZY YEAR, WE
ARE HUMBLED AND GRATEFUL FOR ALL
OF THE PLAYERS EVERYWHER FOR
PLAYING "FORTNITE" AND HELPING
BUILD THEAME WITH THEM.
>> Geoff: IT'S AN ONGOING
GAME, SEASON SEVEN STARTED THIS
MORNING.
WHAT CAN YOUOU TELL US?
>> AS YOU SAW IN THE TRAER, A
BIG MYSTETERIOUS ICEBERG HAS
CRASHED WITH THE ISLAND AND HAS
BROUGHT WITH IT AIRPLANES AND
ZIP LINES AND A WHE BUNCH OF
OTHEHER SURPRISES THAT PLAYERS
WILL BE UNCOVERINGNG IN THE WEES
TO COME.
>> G Geoff: Y ALSO ANNOUNCED
THE CREATIVE MODE?
>> "FORTNITE" CREATIVE IS
LAUNCHING ON SEPTEMBMBER 13TH.
IT'S A BRAND-NEW MODODE WHERE
EVERYONE WILL BE GIVEN THEIR OWN
PRIVATE ISLAND, YOU CAN DESIGN
YOUR OWN GAMES AND BUILD
WHATEVER YOU WANT WIWITH YOUR
FRIENDS.
THIS IS S A REAL LABOR OF LOVE R
US..
WE ARE ALL PASSIONATE GAME
DESIGNERS AND WE THINK EVERYONE
IS A GAME DESIGNER.
OUR GOAL ISIS TO LET YOU BUBUILD
YOUR OWN "FORTNITE"
."IT'S ROUGY
ACCECESS IS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
IF YOUANT TO GET INTO IT RIG
THIS SECOND, JOIN US RIGHT NOW
IN THIS EARLY ACCESS WEEK..
>> Geoff: I HEAR THERE'S'S
SOMETHING MORE?
>> JUST IN A FEW HOURS IT'S BEEN
OUT WE'VE SEE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE B BUILDING CRARAZY, CRAZY
STUFF AND WE SUSPECTED THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN.
THE MAP IS CROWDED ON THE ISLAND
AND WE FIGURED WE NEEDED TO
CLEAR OUT A LITTLE SPACE TO MAKE
ROOM FOR SOME STUFF.
>> Geoeoff: SHOULD WE HEAD OVER
TO THE GAME N?
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENINING IN THE
"FORTNITE" WORLDLD..
♪ ♪
>>eoff: THAT LITERALLY JUST
HAPPENEDN THE GAME.
>> WHAT YOU JUST SAW WAS THE
EMERGENCE OF THE BLOCK.
IT'S A NEW SPACE WHERE WE WILL
BE F FEATURING THE BEST AND
COOLEST CONTENT CREATED BY YOU.
WE WILL BE BRIING IT INTO THE
BATTLE ROYALE MAP ON THE ISLANAD
AND PLACE IT THERE FOR EVERYONE
TO SEE.
WE ARE GOING TO ALL PICKET
TOGETHER.
IF THERE IS NEW STUFF COMINGG
THERALL THE TIME AND WE INK
'S GOING TOO BE AN INCREDIBLE
WAY FOR US TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
THIS GAMEE TOGETHER.
WE WANT IF I LOAD "FORTNITE"
RIGHT NOW, I WILL SEE E THE BLO.
WEILL FIND A WAY TO GET MOVIES
CK IN THERE, IT WILL WORK ON
IT.
>> Geoff: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR STOPPIPING BY THE G GAME AW,
WE CAN'T WAITO SEE WHE YOU
TAKE "FORTNITE" IN THE FUTURE.
NONOW WE GOT A BRAND-NEW LOOK AT
RAGE 2, TAKE A LOOK AT TS.
♪ ♪
♪
>> WE PRESENT BESEST ONGOING GA,
AND THEN "THE GAME AWARDS"
ORCHESTRA CELEBRATES THE
NOMINEES FOR GAME OF THTHE YEAR,
WILL IT BE RED DEAD REDEMPTION
TWO, "GOD OF WAR," OR WILL
ANOTHER GAME TAKE HE THE
CROWN?
IT'S ALL COMING UP.
♪ ♪
>> CRITICS AGREE FINAL FANTASY
14 ONLINE RISES ABOVE
EXPECTATIONS.
A WORLD THAT GROWS BEYOND
IMAGINATION.
WITH AWE-INSPIRING LANDS AS WELL
AS SOME FAMILIAR WORLDS TO
REVISIT.FINAL FANTASY IV ONLINE
CONTINUES TO ASTOUND PLAYERS
WORLDWIDE, BEGIN YOUR ADVENTURE,
LIVE YOUR STORY, FIGHT YOUR W.
FINAL FANTASY IV ONLINE.
PLAY F FREE NOW.
>> SUPER SMASH BROTHERS ULTIMATE
COMING SOON, VY, VERY SOON.
E ULTIMATE SHOWDOWN IS ABOUT
TO BEGIN!
♪ ♪
>> STAY ALIVE AND BE THE ONE.
"PUBG MOBILE," PLAY EE NOW.
>> IN "PUBG MOBILE" THERE CAN
ONLY BE ONE WINNER, THAT'S KIND
OF HARD WHEN YOU'RE FACING OVER
A MILLION PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
IF YOU THINK YOU HAVE WHAT IT
TAKES, DOWNLOA THE GAME RIGHT
NOW, IT'S FREE.
THE ONLY THING YOU HAVE TO LOSE
IS BRAGGING RIGHTS.
♪ ♪
>> "PUBG MOBILE," PLAY IT FREE
NOW.
>> PLEASE WELCOME THE DIRECTING
DUO BEHIND AVENGERS INFINITY WA
WAR.
JOE AND ANTHONY RUSSO.
>> MY BROTHER AND I ARE THRILLED
BE HERE TONIGHT TO HANDOUT
THE AWARD FOR BEST ONGOING GAME.
THIS AWARD IS FOR THOSE GAMES
THAT CONTINUE TO GET BETTER AND
BETTER AFTER THEIR INITIAL
RELEASE.
WITH NEW ADVENTURES AND
EXPERIENCES FOR THEIR FANS.
>> ORIGINALLY THERE WERE TEN
NOMINEES IN THIS CATEGORY, THEY
ASKED US TO PRESENT THE AWARD
AND NOW --
[LAUGHTER]
THERE ARE ONLY FIVE.
>> SORRY.
>> BEST ONGOING GAME.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> END OF GAME AWARD GOES TO...
"FORTNITE"
."
>> "FORTNITE" ALSO WINS FOR BEST
MULTIPLAYERAME.
>> THE RUSSO BROTHERS.
WE LOVE YOU SO MUCH, ALL OF US.
MAKE YOU SO MUCH.
FOR EVERYTHING YOU GUYS HAVE
DONENE FOR US.
I REPRESENT THE TEENIEST PORTION
OF THE TEAM THAT JUST WORKS SO
HARD EVERY DAY TO MAKE THE GAME
THAT IS "FORTNITE"
."THERE ARE E
POURING THEIR SOULS AND TALENT
AND TIME INTO TRYING EVERY DAY
TO BRING ALL THE PEOPLE PLAYING
THAT GAME JOY AND D DELIGHT.
THAT'S OUR MISSION, HOW CAN WE
BRING JOY AND DELIGHT TO PEOPLE?
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL, SO GRATEFUL
FOR ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME ON THIS JOURNEY WITH US,
WHO HAVE PLAYED "FORTNITE," WHO
CONTINUE TO PLAY IT EVERY DAY
AND WITH HIS HELP MAKE THE GAME
BETTER.
THIS HAS BEEN AN EXTREMELY
HUMBLING YEAR FOR US AT EPIC AS
WE'VE REALLY LEARNED AND TRIED
TO JUST DO SOMETHING THAT FELT
WONDERFUL TO US.
WE ARE SO GLAD THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY OF YOU THAT AGREE WITH US.
WERE PLAYING THE GAME WITH US.
I IMAGINE ALMOST EVERYONE HERE,
THE REASON WHY YOU WERE IN THE
GAME INDUSTRY OR WHY YOU MAKE
GAMES OR LOVE GAMES IS BECAUSE
IT FEELS LIKE A NEW MEDIUM.
GAMES AREN'T THAT OLD.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S SO
EXCITING FOR ME, THE FEELING
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING OVER THE
HORIZON.
IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE THERE AGAIN
THAT WE ARE ON THE CUSP AS AN
INDUSTRY OF AMAZING EXPERIENCES.
I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF YOU,
WE ARE ALL ONE BIG TEAM IN THIS
INDUSTRY PUSHING THIS MEDIUM.
I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR IT,
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
♪ ♪
>> STILL LOTS OF AMAZING MOMENTS
COMING UP IN THE SHOW, WE'VE GOT
PERFORMANCES AND OF COURSE THE
GAME OF THE YEAR ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
OKAY.
>> THIS IS JOKER, I'VE
INFILTRATED THE THEATER.
>> HE WENT ALONE TO THE GAM
AWARDS?
IT'S SO FAR AWAY, WHY HE IS HE
THERE.
>> HE'S THERE TO STEAL A
TREASURE.
>> WE AREN'N'T THE ONE SENDING A
CARD THIS TIME.
WE'VE BEEN INVITED.
INVITED TO STEAL THE GREATEST
TREASURE OF ALL.
SMASH BROTHERS, IS THIS FOR
REAL?
WILL BE GOING UP AGAINST THE
BEST OF THE BEST.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE OUR FEARLESS
LEADER SHOW IT.
>> I AM -- RAGE AGAINST ALL
CHALLENGERS.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: OH REGGIE, WE MEET
AGAIN.
QUITE THE SURPRISE.
SUPER SMASH BROTHERS COMING OUT
TONIGHT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE A
GREAT CHOICE OF SHIRT.
THE INTERNET IS GOING CRAZY THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF JOKER FROM
PERSONA FIVE COMING TO SMASH
BROTHERS.
>> WE'VE SAIAID SUPER SMASH
BROTHERS ULTIMATE THE BIGGEST
CROSSOVER IN VIDEO GAME HISTORY,
DARE I SAY THE BIGGEST CROSSOVER
AND ENTERTAINMENT.
>> THE RUSSO BROTHERS MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
>> THE GAME IS ABOUT TO LAUNCH,
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED, SUPER
EXCITED TO GIVE THE FANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUMMON A PERSONA
INTO THE GAME.
>> Geoff: YOU SAID CHALLENGER
PACK ONE >> EACH CHARACTER WILL
COME WITH THE STAGE, A SELECTION
OF MUSIC, THESE WILL BE CHARACTT
ARE NEW TO THE SERIES JUST LIKE
JOKER FROM PERSONA FIVE,
CHARACTERS THAT YOU WOULD NOT
ANTICIPATE TO BE IN SUPER SMASH
BROTHE ULTIMATE.
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
THE FANS CAN GO AND GET THE
FIGHTERS PASS TO GET ALL OF THE
FIVE FIGHTERS, WE ARE
TREMENDOUSLY EXCITED.
>> Geoff: TONIGHT, SMASH IS
ABOUT TO LAUNCH.
>> SMASH IS ABOUT TO LAUNCH.
YOU KNOW YOU NEEDED TO HAVE A
REALLYOOD SHOW R ME TO BE
HERE, MAKING SURE EVERYTHING I
GOING GREAT FOR THE LAUNCH.
WE ARE SUPER EXCITED,, SMASH IS
MINUTES AWAY AND WE
IT'S GOINO
BE FANANTASTIC.
>> Geoff: : YOU'VE BEEN N RE
EVERY YEAR.
BEFORE WE GO, MAYBE WE SHOULD
HEAD FOR THE STAGE TO
FOR "THE
AWARDS" ORCHESTRA, MAY BE A
LITTLE SOMETHING FOR SUPER SMASH
BROTHERS.
♪ ♪
>> ONE MORE BIG SCORE, WE HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO LEAVE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> NOTHING MEANS MORE TO ME THAN
THIS GANG.
I WOULD KILL FOR IT, I WOULD
HAPPY DIE FOR IT.
>> IT WASN'T US WHO CHANGED.
>> TRUST M ARTHUR.
>> I WANT TO KILL ALL OF THEM,
JUST YOU.
>> WHAT ABOUT LOYALTY?
>> DO WHAT YOU'RE TOLD.
>> "RED DEAD REDEMPTION 2" OUT
NOW, RATED M FOR MATURE.
♪ ♪
>> YOU START WITH THIS GAME
BUILDING A SOUND IDENTITY, SO I
KIND OF STARTED FOR SCRATCH WITH
THIS ONE AND THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT
ARE THE MINDSETS AND HOW CAN WE
BRING IT FORWARD WITH THE SOUND?
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> A LOT OF TIMES YOU THINK IT
GOES THIWAY.
HUGE SOUNDSCAPE IT MAKES IT MORE
LIKE IT COVERS YOU AND IT'S
MAGICAL.
>> YOU'RE FINDING THAT YOU ARE
THIS CHARACTER, THAT YOU ARE
LARA CROFT.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: IT'S FINALLY THAT
TIME, HERE TO PRESENT OUR FINAL
AWARD IS A MEMBER OF THE TEAM
THAT WON GAME OF THE YEAR IN
2016 AND ONE LAST YEAROR
"OVERWATCH," HE IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF BLIZZARD
ENTERTAINMENT, JEFF KAPLAN.
>> TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE HONORED
TO BE APPEAR TO ACCEPT THE GAME
OF THE YEAR FOR "OVERWATCH."
IT WAS SO AWESOME AND IT MEANT
SO MUCH TO OUR TEAM.
IT'S SO SPECIAL RIGHT NOW TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE THAT WITH ANOTHER
STUDIO..
HERE TO CELEBRATE ALL OF THE
NOMINEES FOR GAME OF THE YEAR,
THE GAME AWARDS ORCHESTRA.
♪ ♪
>> Geoff: ALL RIGHT.
>> LOTTIE DOTTIE, WHO GETS THE
GOTY.
AND THE GAME AWARD GAME OF THE
YEAR GOES TO "GOD OF WAR"
."
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> SO UNEXPECTED, THANK YOU
EVERYBODY,
.
IT'S A GREAT NIGHT FOR ALL OF U
US.
THANKS SO MUCH TO THE TEAM BACK
IN SANTA MONICA, AN AMAZING
GROUP OF TALENT THAT REALL
PULLED TOGETHER TO REALIZE THIS
BEAUTIFUL VISION THAT COREY
BROUGHT TO THE FRANCHISE REBOOT
TO "GOD OF WAR"
."
I'I'M SO THANKFUL THAT COREY
RETURNED BACK TO THE STUDIDIO AD
JOINED OUR FAMILY ONCE AGAIN.
YOU ARE AN AMAZING VISIONARY, I
LOVE YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
IT'S HARD TO SEEEE ALL THE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES WORK THAT GOES
INTO PRODUCING "GOD OF WAR" AND
THE TRIUMPH, STEADFAST ABILITY
TO THREAD THAT PRODUCTION NEEDLE
AND THE CREATIVE VISION WE WOULD
NOT BE WHERE WE ARE ON THIS
STAGE TODAY.
THANK YOU TO THE ENTIRE
PRODUCTION TEAM.
THE FANS AROUND THE WORLD
TOGETHER WE ALL DREAM BIG DREAM
DREAMS.
THAT'S AN AMAZING FEELING EVERY
DAY WHEN WE WALKED T THROUGH THE
STUDIO TO CREATE SOMETHING LIKE
"GOD OF WAR."
I WANT TO THANK MY CHILDREN FORF
R" TEAM, THANK YOU SO MUCH FORTR
THE COURSE OF MANY, MANY MONTHS,
MANY HOURS, MANY YEARS.
LALASTLY, TRYING TO SUPPORT
SANTA A MONICA STUDIOO,
.
[APPLAUSE]
RE-ENVISIONING OF THIS FRANCHISE
WHICH TAKES A LOT OF GUTS AT
THAT LEVEL AND THE ENTIRE FAMILY
WHO STOOD BEHIND US IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP OVER MANY YEARS TO
REALIZ WHAT THIS FRANCHISE IS
CAPABLE OF.
>> I WANT TO SAY EVERY SINGLE
GAME THAT WAS NOMINATED UP HERE
IS AN ABSOLUTE MASTERPIECE.
PLEASE GIVE IT UP FOR ALL OF
THEM.
AGAIN, PLEASE GIVE IT UP FOR
EVERY CREATOR AND CREATORS OF
GAMEMES, MOVIES, C COMICOOKS,
CREATORS OF EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT ENRICHES OUR L LIVES, THATT
MAKES US BELIEVE MAGIC IS REAL.
I LOVE YOU.
♪ ♪
♪♪ ♪♪
>> Geoff: CONGRATULATIONS TO
THE "GOD OF WAR" TM, LET'S
CHECK THTHE TWITCH LEADERBOARD O
SEE WHO WAS THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PREDICTING WINNERS TONIGHTHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WATCHING
"THE GAME AWARDS," WE'LL SEE YOU
NEXT YEAR FOR "THE GAME AWARDRD"
2019.
I APPRECIATE IT, GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]